Krass!
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 93 und außerdem die zweite Live-Sendung auf Funkwelle FM. Da sitzen wir hier im Studio. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch sehr herzlich auch zu dieser Ausgabe, die unter den gewohnt chaotischen Umständen hier im Sendestudio von Funkwelle schön roh und nackt über den ETA gesendet wird zusätzlich zu unserer normalen Ausstrahlung über das Internet. Uns gibt es also auch als Stream. Wir haben jetzt hier auch unseren eigenen Grad mal organisiert, weil, wie es aussieht, sind die Jungs von Micro FM, die sich sonst um ihren Stream kümmern, sonnen sich gerade irgendwie auf irgendeiner Open-Air-Party, halten den Bauch in die Sonne und da mussten wir jetzt hier mal ganz kurzfristig die Technologie bemühen. Aber das macht ja gar nichts aus, weil das ist Chaosradio Express und hier geht es um Technik und Gesellschaft. Ich will auch noch mal kurz für die Leute, die hier zuhören und noch nicht wissen, was Chaosradio Express ist, kurz einleiten. Chaosradio Express ist ein Podcast, der unregelmäßig erscheint im Internet, kann man also abonnieren und hören und hier gibt es immer interessante Interviews zu einem großen Spektrum von Themen, die häufig viel mit Technik, Technologie zu tun haben, aber da Technologie heutzutage auch mal viel mit unserer Gesellschaft zu tun hat, hat auch Chaosradio Express viel mit der Gesellschaft zu tun. Und so soll es auch diesmal wieder sein, nachdem wir uns hier letzte Woche von 15 bis 17 Uhr sende ich jetzt hier mal jeden Sonntag, auch noch die nächsten beiden Sonntage, nachdem wir uns hier letzte Woche eigentlich mit Gregor unterhalten über Poststrukturalismus, beziehungsweise wir wollten uns über Poststrukturalismus unterhalten und haben das auch irgendwie getan, aber zwei Stunden sind für so ein komplexes Thema dann doch immer schon eine ganz schöne Herausforderung. Trotzdem sind viele interessante Aspekte rausgekommen, aber vielleicht machen wir noch mal einen zweiten Teil. Aber nicht heute, sondern heute geht es um die Wikipedia und ich begrüße schon mal hier zu meiner Rechten Maha, hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Martin Haase, du bist schon ein paar mal bei Chaosradio Express dabei gewesen. Wir haben uns schon über allerlei interessantes Zeug unterhalten, unter anderem haben wir uns über Sprachen unterhalten, weil du bist Sprachwissenschaftler. Das war schon mal eine sehr aufschlussreiche Sendung. Eine andere Sendung ging jüngst über den Neussprech im Schnüffelstaat, wo wir ein bisschen den Politikern aufs Maul geschaut haben. Aber wir haben auch schon eine Sendung gemacht zur Wikipedia, in der du seit vielen Jahren sehr aktiv bist. So haben wir uns auch mal kennengelernt und wollten jetzt heute dem mal einen, ja kann man sagen, zweiten Teil, ja eine Fortsetzung auf jeden Fall angedeihen lassen. Mit einem Schwerpunkt, der Schwerpunkt ist die, ja, hochlodernde Qualitätsdebatte, aber nicht nur die Debatte, sondern alle Aspekte der Qualitätssicherung in der Wikipedia, die ja alle irgendwie betrifft. Ja, und wo ich jetzt sowieso schon so schön am einleiten und erklären bin, für Neueinsteiger hier für Chaosradio Express nochmal die wichtigsten Ressourcen vorab, chaosradio.ccc.de, da findet ihr das ganze Angebot von unserem Podcast und auf dem Blog könnt ihr auch kommentieren zu dieser Sendung. So, jetzt haben wir das abgehakt, Maha, jetzt geht's los. Wikipedia, immer noch dein Thema. Du bist da schon lange mit dabei, stimmt's?
Ja das stimmt, also ich bin ja ziemlich früh dazu gekommen, 2003, und dann haben wir uns ja auch gleich kennengelernt auf den ersten Stammtischen und ja, seitdem hat sich natürlich einiges getan. Also insbesondere 2003 war es ja so, dass niemand dachte, dass die Wikipedia irgendwie ernst zu nehmen sei und inzwischen ist sie ja gar nicht mehr wegzudenken und es hat sich wirklich auch ziemlich viel getan. Also es gibt viele neue Features, es gibt dieses ganze Verfahren des Qualitätsmanagements und die wir uns ja heute auch mit dem wir uns ja heute auch beschäftigen wollen. Also da ist wirklich viel passiert, das hat sich sehr verändert. Man hat fast das Gefühl, wenn ich so zurückdenke damals, als wir uns ja auch kennengelernt haben, das war irgendwie so eine Art Steinzeit zur heutigen Zeit. Also das kann man eigentlich gar nicht mehr vergleichen.
Ja, also ich könnte mir das schon für Chaosradio Express nicht vorstellen. Ich mache ja immer sehr viele Links zu der Sendung, wenn ich danach noch mal die Zeit finde, es nachzuhören. In der Regel tue ich das. Bei den Live-Sendungen ist es immer ein bisschen schwierig, weil wir immer auch schnell online stellen. Letztes Mal war ich ein bisschen faul, aber das hole ich vielleicht noch nach. So, aber 80 bis 90 Prozent der Links, die ich eigentlich zu einer guten Diskussion über Thema XY finde, da linkt man einfach am besten auf die Wikipedia. Das ist einfach am sinnvollsten, gerade weil dort eigentlich so der Trend herrscht, alles Relevante zusammen zu kratzen. Ich könnte natürlich, was weiß ich, wenn es um irgendein Projekt geht, auch auf die Homepage verweisen, aber ich muss feststellen, dass also ein Artikel über ein Projekt in der Wikipedia viel mehr Mehrwert und auch Einsteigerbasiswissen vermittelt, als es die Homepages der Projekte in der Regel selbst tun können.
Und vor allen Dingen bist du eigentlich sicher, dass bei der Wikipedia eigentlich auch der Link irgendwie so bleibt, bei den Projekten, da ändern die mal was, dann machen die ein Content-Management-System und dann stimmen die links nicht mehr und so. Das ist also ein bisschen ein Problem, das ist auch der Grund, warum viele Leute es vorziehen, auf die Wikipedia zu linken und du hast natürlich wirklich den Mehrwert und du hast auch den neutralen Standpunkt, der bleibt doch irgendwie gewahrt, während wenn du auf irgendeine Seite direkt verlinkst, da kann da plötzlich ein Standpunkt kommen, der gar nicht mehr so passt oder dann ist es gar nicht mehr so, wie man sich das eigentlich mal dachte, während bei der Wikipedia zumindest so eine Garantie da ist, dass eben auch, dass noch in ein paar Jahren irgendwie brauchbar ist, die Informationen, die da stehen.
Aber mit den stabilen Links, das stimmt natürlich nicht ganz so, weil, sag mal, keine Ahnung, ich hab jetzt irgendeinen Begriff, da link ich jetzt drauf, ja, und sag mal mal, das ist so eine gängige Abkürzung. A, B, C, man fällt ja natürlich jetzt kein gutes Beispiel ein, aber ich hatte das schon so ein paar mal. Dann ist das ja auch so, dass wenn, korrigier mich, aber soweit ich das erinnere, in der Wikipedia gilt es so, ein Artikel hat unter dem Namen zu erscheinen, unter dem er am meisten bekannt ist. So, das heißt, wenn das wirklich so was ist, wie, ja, ist es so eine Sache, was jetzt ein gutes Beispiel wäre, fällt dir grad zufällig was ein, wie auch immer. Also, denn existiert einfach dieser Artikel unter dieser Abkürzung. Später allerdings, da muss ich halt auch dahin linken, x, y, z. Später allerdings kommt dann irgendwas in die Medien oder wird sonst wie von heute auf morgen total bekannt oder wird überhaupt erst mal eingetragen, was vorher vergessen worden ist. So, und dann lande ich halt auf so einer Begriffsklärungsseite. Und da stimmt natürlich dann mein alter Link auch nicht mehr. Also, das ist noch ein ungelöstes Problem, wie man so einen Link so machen kann, dass er eben auch zukunftskompatibel ist.
Du kommst aber da dann über die Begriffsklärungsseite dann auch wieder auf die Seite.
Ja, aber dann musst du auch wissen, der Witz ist, ich linke hier an die Wikipedia um dieses, verstehst du, dieses mal eben beiläufig erwähnte Detail, was ich typischerweise, wenn ich mit irgendeinem Tiefnerd unterhalte, der plappert dann halt einfach los und so, das kennt man ja auch hier irgendwie bei XYZ und CBS und NMI und Schnickschnack und so. Und um überhaupt eine Möglichkeit zu geben, diesen Kontext, der da mal so beiläufig gesagt wurde, zu erfassen, link ich da halt auch noch hin. Bloß wenn mir der dann verloren geht, wird es schwierig. Was man also bräuchte, kurz mal nachgedacht, ist Links, die quasi den Tag mit codieren. Also ich will gerne einen Link auf diesen Artikel haben. Ja und möchte sagen, diesen Link, ja wie denn?
Ja mit der Versionsnummer. Du kannst auf eine ganz bestimmte Version verlinken. Also das ist...
Ja, aber das funktioniert ja dann nicht mehr, wenn der Begriff selbst gewechselt wurde.
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Also die Version ist eindeutig, bleibt doch noch bestehen, wenn der Artikel... also nicht immer.
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Weil wenn ich... jetzt nehme ich mal irgendwie ein Beispiel. Nehmen wir mal an, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so BKA, das Bundeskriminalamt wäre jetzt erstmal unter BKA geführt worden. Zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich diesen Link in meinen Blog oder wo auch immer setze, link ich dann halt auf BKA. Später wird da aber Bundeskriminalamt raus und dann gibt es noch was anderes, was BKA heißt und dann linkt BKA halt auf Dingsbums. Da nützt mir die Version jetzt auch nichts, weil diese Version in dem BKA Begriffsklärungsseite halt nicht mehr, den gibt es da gar nicht.
Doch, die Seite bleibt erhalten unter dieser Nummer. Die Versionsnummer ist eindeutig und das ist nicht die Nummer des Artikels BKA, den es da nicht mehr gibt, sondern die Versionsnummer, obwohl sie Versionsnummer heißt, ist die Nummer genau dieser Seite. Das heißt also, wenn es BKA verschoben wird nach Bundeskriminalamt, hast du immer noch diese Version, also die gibt es noch.
Okay, aber...
Die kann auch gelöscht werden, aber das wären Sonderfälle.
Wie kriege ich denn diese...
Ja, das ist leider, das ist lange, da sage ich schon seit langem, dass da mal was geändert werden muss. Die kriegst du leider nur, indem du auf Versionen Autoren gehst und wenn du dann auf eine Version klickst, das kann auch die neueste sein, dann erscheint als Link die Versionsnummer.
Ja, aber der ist doch immer noch der Name mit drin.
Ja, der Name ist dabei, aber der ist nur dabei, damit man diesen Link auch versteht. Also die eigentliche Nummer ist die Versionsnummer und die ist eindeutig. Das ist also nicht die Version dieses Artikels, sondern überhaupt die Nummer dieser Seite. Da steht auch Old Version davor, selbst wenn es nicht die Old Version ist, also selbst wenn es die neueste ist.
Okay, du meinst jetzt diesen Link hier, wo dann irgendwie Title lalala und Old ID gleich hmhmhm.
Genau, und diese, diese ID ist eigentlich eindeutig, auch wenn man das so nicht sehen kann.
Das heißt, ich kann diesen Title auch weglassen?
Genau, den kannst du weglassen.
Das probier ich jetzt mal aus.
Ja, dann mach.
Also nur Old ID?
Genau, da müsste genau diese Seite kommen.
Hm, das stimmt.
Ja, siehste, also weißt du, wie es geht.
Okay, cool. Jetzt hätte ich aber gerne noch so den Parameter dazu und bitte auf die aktuelle Version, verstehst du? Und der Seite?
Das geht leider nicht.
Okay, dann hätten wir schon mal unseren ersten Feature-Request durch.
Ja, aber das ist leicht. Da kannst du mit so einem kleinen JavaScript-Ding das auch hinbekommen, dass er dann die neueste Version davon nimmt.
Okay.
Also das wäre machbar. Ich kann es jetzt nicht, weil ich jetzt nicht so schnell so was programmieren kann.
Wir leiten das mal weiter. In der Hoffnung, dass auch die Wikipedia-Programmierer hier mithören. So, hier klingelt das Telefon. Das ist aber jetzt noch kein Anruf für uns. Ob wir hier Anrufer mit reinnehmen, wissen wir noch nicht. Wir müssen erst mal gucken, wie weit wir hier mit unserem Thema kommen. Und vielleicht machen wir das später dann noch. So, ja, jetzt sind wir ja schon mal schön eingestiegen in ein vollkommen anderes Thema. Aber vielleicht hat auch das was mit Qualität zu tun, zumindest mit der Qualität der Nutzbarkeit des Systems.
Also das ist auch ein bisschen wenig bekannt, dass es diese Versionsnummern gibt. Aber das ist eigentlich sehr sinnvoll. Also wenn ich irgendwie was zitiere, ich sage jetzt mal für eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit, gut, das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit sein, aber man schreibt ja wissenschaftliche Arbeiten vielleicht auch im Studium oder in der Schule oder so. Und man möchte jetzt was zitieren aus der Wikipedia, dann tut man natürlich sehr gut daran, diese Versionsnummer anzugeben. Und nicht einfach den Artikelnamen, weil sich der Artikel geändern kann und dann findet man das Zitat nicht wieder.
Eben, eben.
Das ist ganz dumm. Deshalb sollte man wirklich darauf achten, dass man die Versionsnummer angibt. Das ist auch ein Vorteil gegenüber dem Zitieren von anderen Webseiten. Da kann man immer nur hinschreiben, in sein Zitat hinten stand, was weiß ich, 3.01.2008. Hier hat man die exakte Versionsnummer und findet wirklich das Zitat wieder. Denn bei so einem schnelllebigen Instrument wie der Wikipedia kann ja natürlich am 3.01.2008 zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit kann es ja mehrere Änderungen geben, sogar innerhalb einer Sekunde. Also ganz eindeutig ist das nicht.
Aber die Versionsnummer ist eindeutig. Es könnte sogar sein, dass der Begriff dann gar nicht mehr da ist.
Genau, ja. Und mit der Versionsnummer findet man es dann eben.
Weil er nicht mehr relevant ist. Aber da reden wir mal später drüber. Jetzt wollte ich noch mal ein bisschen anknüpfen. Wir hatten in der letzten Sendung viel über das Wikipedia-Projekt gesprochen. Also mehr nur als jetzt das eigentliche Lexikon, was natürlich jeder kennt. Aber Wikipedia oder sagen wir mal das Wikimedia-Projekt. Also es gibt ja alle eine Foundation, die dahinter steht, die Wikimedia Foundation. Wo hat die jetzt ihren Sitz eigentlich? Wo der Jimmy Wales, der Gründer herkommt. Und ich meine, hat die da nur einen Briefkasten? Oder ist die da auch?
Ja, die ist da auch. Also da gibt es tatsächlich auch Leute, die da arbeiten. Auch unabhängig von Jimmy Wales, der ja damit eigentlich jetzt nichts mehr zu tun hat. Das ist der Chef eines privaten Unternehmens, nämlich wikia.com.
Ah ja, diese Suchmaschine auf Wikibasis.
Ne, ne, ne. Das ist ein Nebenprojekt von Wikia. Wikia ist eigentlich ein Anbieter für Wikis. Wo man halt ein Wiki machen kann, wo man irgendeinen Themenbereich bearbeiten will. Also so ein Fan-Wiki zum Beispiel, was jetzt nicht in die Wikipedia passt. Man möchte zum Beispiel zu den Simpsons alle Details, die man nur irgendwie wissen kann, in Form eines Wikis aufbereiten. Dann würde das nicht in die Wikipedia passen. Da könnte es natürlich, je nachdem, auch Seiten über die einzelnen Simpsons-Charaktere geben. Aber wirklich alles und jede Kleinigkeit, das wäre dann zu viel für die Wikipedia. Und da kann man eben dann ein Simpsons-Wiki machen. Beziehungsweise das gibt es auch. Wikia läuft werbefinanziert. Das heißt, die Nutzer dieses Fan-Wikis müssen dann eben mit Werbung leben. Und damit kann man natürlich für alle möglichen Themenbereiche wirklich so...
Mal eben sich ein Wiki klicken. Das ist nämlich ein echtes Problem. Ein eigenes Wiki aufsetzen erfordert natürlich schon gewisse Grundkenntnisse. Und das ist nicht ganz unknifflig. Insbesondere die permanente Aktualisierung wegen Sicherheitsproblematiken und so. Das will man eigentlich doch lieber mal aus der Hand rausgeben.
Genau, das übernimmt Wikia. Das Problem ist halt nur, dass man da eben Werbung hat. Ich glaube, es gibt aber auch ein Modus, dass man, wenn man mehr Geld zahlt, auch keine Werbung haben kann und so. Das ist halt natürlich ein Unternehmen, das das macht. Das ist jetzt aber unabhängig von der Wikipedia. Das ist eben nur eine Gründung von Jimmy Rayes, der damit eben auch Geld verdienen will und der auch natürlich noch andere Sachen damit macht. Zum Beispiel diese Suchmaschine ist auch im Rahmen dieser Firma entwickelt worden. Also Wikia Search, wie gut die Suchmaschine ist, darüber gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche Meinungen. Also ich kann dazu eigentlich nicht viel sagen, weil ich es kurz getestet habe und dann festgestellt habe, dass ich doch nicht das daraus bekomme, was ich sonst bekomme. Und ich habe also jetzt über Monate das nicht mehr genutzt. Deshalb kann ich jetzt kein aktuelles Statement zu Wikia Search angeben.
Geht mir ähnlich. Ich meine, das Problem ist, die treten dann immer groß an. Und sozusagen an ihrem ersten Tag werden sie dann von allen getestet. Ähnliches Schicksal erleitet ja hier gerade diese neue Suchmaschine mit dem unaufsprechlichen Namen. Schon mitbekommen? kuhiil.com schreibt sie irgendwie C-U-I-L. Angeblich soll man das cool aussprechen. Ich weiß ja nicht genau, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben. Also erstens klingt für mich C-U-I-L einfach nicht wie cool. Klingt auch nicht cool. Weder klingt es nach cool, noch klingt es cool. Und was denken die sich dann, was man dann macht im Netz? Coolen? Durchquälen?
Es gibt ja auch noch andere Projekte, also dieses SearchMe, wo man halt so im Stil von McIntosh so kleine Voransichten der Seiten bekommt. Das setzt man auf Google auf. Das ist schon ganz lustig eigentlich, je nachdem was man sucht. Wenn man zum Beispiel mehr so in dem Bereich, ich will mal was Optisches suchen, zum Beispiel irgendwelche Bildchen. Da hat man natürlich große Vorteile, wenn man so eine Suchmaschine hat. Das heißt, das ist ja nur ein Interface zu Google. Also es gibt da schon schöne Sachen. Aber eigentlich wollten wir nicht über Suchmaschinen sprechen, sondern über die Wikimedia Foundation. Da weiß ich auch mehr drüber. Es gibt einen neuen Executive Director der Wikimedia Foundation, nämlich Sue Gardner. Kann man sich auch ansehen, wenn man auf die Seite Sue Gardner in der deutschen Wikipedia geht. Da ist auch ein Foto von ihr. Die ist seit Ende 2007 an der Spitze von der Wikimedia Foundation und ist, glaube ich, ein echter Glücksgriff, denn sie bewegt eine ganze Menge. Es hat sich also einiges verändert. Es sind neue Leute eingestellt worden, zum Beispiel auch ein Deutscher, Frank Schulenburg, der hier die Wikipedia Academy ins Leben gerufen hat. Der macht jetzt bei der Wikimedia Foundation in Florida, er arbeitet dort, hat seinen Schwerpunkt nach Amerika verlagert, und ist dort zuständig, um solche ähnlichen Projekte wie die Wikipedia Academy dann international einzurichten, indem man Fachleute bindet an die Wikipedia mit Hilfe von speziellen Veranstaltungen, die sich an Wissenschaftler richten oder überhaupt an Fachleute richten. Und das, denke ich, ist auch eine tolle Sache. Also da wird jetzt wirklich mal was gemacht. Denn die Wikimedia Foundation über die vergangenen Jahre, eigentlich bis 2007, war so ein bisschen so ein schlafender Riese. Da gab es irgendwie was, die haben immer mal Fundraising gemacht, aber sonst haben sie nichts gemacht. Und das ist eigentlich irgendwie, ja gut, natürlich muss jemand die Serverstruktur aufbauen und als Ansprechpartner da sein, damit es immer mehr Server gibt und so. Das ist natürlich schon wichtig, aber steckt natürlich noch viel mehr Potenzial da drin. Und außer Fundraising muss man natürlich noch ein paar andere Dinge machen. Und das scheint jetzt auch begriffen worden zu sein.
Das war vor allem, weil die Wikimedia so ein beliebtes Klageziel in den letzten Jahren.
Genau, ja, genau.
Hat sich das jetzt ein bisschen gelegt?
Nein, nein, das hat sich überhaupt nicht gelegt. Also ich bin ja jetzt nicht mehr im Vorstand von Wikimedia Deutschland, deshalb kriege ich nicht mehr so viel mit.
Aber jetzt kannst du auspacken.
Aber jetzt kann ich auspacken, genau. Also, ich meine, man hat mich ja aufgefragt, warum ich da nicht mehr mitmache beim Vorstand. Ein Grund ist, dass ich halt kein Jurist bin. Und einfach der Anteil der Zeit, die man mit Klagen, also mit der Diskussion von irgendwelchen Klagen verbracht hat, mir einfach zu viel war. Also das ist wirklich ein großes Problem. Das hat sich auch keineswegs gelegt. Jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser geworden, weil man innerhalb von Wikimedia Deutschland jetzt auch so Arbeitsgruppen gegründet hat. Also es muss nicht immer alles im Vorstand verhandelt werden. Von daher ist die Situation besser geworden. Ich kann also jetzt wieder empfehlen. Man kann in den Vorstand wieder gehen. Aber das ist immer noch ein großes Problem. Und auch eins, was...
Die einzige Wachstumsbranche ist die Juristerei.
Ich glaube, die sind ganz glücklich über die Existenz der Wikipedia. Weil man da leicht gutes Geld verdienen kann als Anwalt. Denn ich meine, es ist ja klar, es gibt immer Leute, die sich durch irgendwas belästigt oder auf den Schnips getreten fühlen. Das muss gar nicht besonders substanziell sein. Und die wenden sich dann an den Anwalt, obwohl sie eigentlich gar keine Chance haben. Glücklicherweise. Aber wie gesagt, Anwälte sind erstmal beschäftigt.
Was heißt, sie haben keine Chance? Das heißt, der Großteil der Klagen läuft ins Nichts?
Ja, genau.
Gibt es auch Gegenbeispiele?
Ja, es gibt auch Gegenbeispiele.
Fällt dir gerade einer ein, der so diskussionswürdig wäre?
Das ist immer schwierig. Das hatten wir schon mal erwähnt, glaube ich, im letzten Podcast. Es gibt tatsächlich jemand, der in der Wikipedia immer auftauchte wegen einer Straftat, aber seine Strafe verbüßt hat und jetzt eigentlich darf nicht mehr dauernd als erster Google-Hit seine Straftat überall stehen. Und da hat er sich auch tatsächlich vor Gericht durchsetzen können gegen die Wikipedia. Es musste also extra eine Taskforce eingesetzt werden, die jetzt darauf achtet, dass so ein guter Mann nicht mehr wieder eingetragen wird. Viele Leute, weil die Sache sehr spektakulär war, erinnern sich an den Namen. Aber das geht so nach deutschem Recht eigentlich nicht. Klar, in irgendwelchen Archiven darf natürlich auch noch die Geschichte aufbereitet sein, aber nicht so, dass der erste Google-Hit immer gleich... Ich meine, der Mann hat sonst keine Chance mehr.
Na klar. Ist das jetzt klar, welches Recht anzuwenden ist? Ich meine, es gibt ja in dem Sinne gar keine deutsche Wiki. Also es gibt eine deutsche Wikipedia, aber das Deutsch bezieht sich ja auf die Sprache und nicht auf Deutschland.
Genau, es gilt auf jeden Fall das US-amerikanische Recht. Es gilt aber auch das deutsche Recht, denn ich meine, das ist in Deutschland ja das Verursacherprinzip. Wenn also hier jemand was verursacht, dann muss er auch hier haftbar gemacht werden. Das ist natürlich das Dumme bei der Wikipedia, dass sozusagen der kleinste gemeinsame Länder gilt. Man muss also das alles beachten. Man muss das deutsche Recht beachten, also bei der deutschen Wikipedia. Man muss das amerikanische Recht beachten, und das ist manchmal richtig lästig.
Aber die deutsche Wikipedia geht ja in dem Sinne gar nicht von Deutschland aus.
Das stimmt, aber die Verursacher sitzen hier.
Na, nicht unbedingt. Ich meine, das kann ja jetzt auf einer Insel irgendwo...
Dann ist es auch nicht so ein Problem. Aber es ist schon so, dass bei der deutschen Wikipedia ein...
Das heißt, es wird erstmal nach der IP-Adresse geguckt, irgendwie welchem Land die zugeordnet wurde?
Ja, wenn man herausfindet, da ist jemand hier, der Mist gebaut hat, kann er auch hier belangt werden.
Okay, aber wenn das von den Antillen kommt, dann ist das alles schon nicht mehr. Also man sieht schon, das Internet macht die Sachen nicht unbedingt immer einfacher. Aber auch darauf wollte ich eigentlich nicht so schwerpunktmäßig zu sprechen kommen. Aber vielleicht bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei Wikimedia, weil das ist so ein Punkt, den wir beim letzten Podcast noch nicht so ausführlich behandelt haben. Also es gibt auch ein Wikimedia in Deutschland, muss man dazu sagen. Inwieweit hängt das dann mit der Foundation in den USA zusammen?
Na ja, erstmal ist natürlich Wikimedia Deutschland ein selbstständiger eingetragener Verein in Deutschland. Da gibt es zunächst mal nur die namentliche Übereinstimmung. Aber die Wikimedia Foundation in den USA hat sich zum Ziel gesetzt, so nationale Gruppen zusammenzufassen. Obwohl die Wikimedia Foundation eine Stiftung ist, also eine, die keine Mitglieder hat, wird trotzdem dort gesagt, wir haben sogenannte National- oder Local-Chapters, also Untergruppen. Wikimedia Deutschland ist halt so eine Untergruppe. Da die Foundation kein Verein ist mit so einer Satzung, wo das genau aufgeführt ist, ist das mehr so gewohnt als recht. Wikimedia Deutschland, und das steht auch dort in der Satzung, fühlt sich eben auch als Landesverband von der Wikimedia Foundation. Von daher besteht auch ein Zusammenhang.
Und gibt es in vielen Ländern so eine Struktur? Oder ist das jetzt wieder nur die Deutschen brauchen?
Nee, es gibt das in Frankreich, es gibt das in Italien. Kroatien ist sehr aktiv, Polen ist sehr aktiv. Insbesondere in Europa, würde ich mal sagen. Ich bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher. Ich glaube, in Israel gibt es auch eine. Also es gibt vor allen Dingen in Europa solche nationalen oder Landesverbände, sagen wir mal.
Ein weiteres Ding, wo ich mir nicht ganz so sicher bin, ob wir das letzte Mal eigentlich angesprochen haben, aber was jetzt gerade mal wieder lief, ich weiß, so war es nicht da, aber ich will es trotzdem mal ansprechen, ist die Wikimania-Konferenz, die ja sozusagen so ein bisschen die Love Parade der Wikipedianer ist, die fing ja auch in Deutschland an.
Genau, 2005 in Frankfurt war die erste Wikimania.
Da warst du dabei.
Da war ich dabei.
Und dann war sie, glaube ich, in den USA?
Dann war sie genau, in Boston, also in der Harvard University.
Warst du da auch?
Da war ich nicht. Also es ist ja nicht Boston, Cambridge, Massachusetts bei Boston und dann dieses Jahr in Alexandria, in Ägypten.
Das heißt, ein Jahr war keine?
Doch, doch, da war auch eine. Moment, da muss ich erst mal nachgucken, wo die davor war.
Also erst Frankfurt, dann Cambridge.
Genau.
War da nicht eine in Asien?
Genau, Taipei, ja, Entschuldigung.
Genau. So, und jetzt ging es nach Ägypten. Wo haben die dann in dieser alten Bibliothek abgehangen?
Nein, alt ist die ja nicht, das ist ein Neubau, aber da gab es mal eine in der Bibliothek.
Und, hast du irgendwas davon gehört?
Ja, ich hab mal mit den Leuten telefoniert. Also es ist wohl, war natürlich wieder eine beeindruckende Veranstaltung. Viele Leute haben jetzt auch mal direkt mit Sue Gardner sprechen können und so. Das war eigentlich vor allen Dingen das, was ich so am Telefon gehört habe, dass sie alle ganz begeistert waren von der neuen Direktorin. Und ja, dass also tatsächlich auch so ein gewisses internationales Gefühl da aufgekommen ist.
Teil dir mal zahlen, so ein etwa?
Da hab ich jetzt keine Ahnung. Das müsste man schnell nachschauen.
Aber es sind wahrscheinlich so einige zusammengekommen. Also ist es denn international dann auch wirklich?
Ja, genau. Das war eben auch das, was jetzt so als Gefühl da war. Ich meine, gut, natürlich, auch wenn es in Taipei stattfindet, ist es international. Aber da gab es natürlich dann auch erstmal eine starke lokale Fraktion und so. Und so ein richtig internationales Gefühl muss wohl jetzt auch in Alexandria stärker gewesen sein als die Male davor.
Tja, da wäre ich auch gerne gewesen, muss ich ehrlich gesagt sagen. So in Gippen war ich noch nicht. Und so in der Bibliothek über die moderne Variante davon zu sprechen, das ist noch mal ein netter Kick, oder?
Ich denke auch, das ist bestimmt interessant. Also mir wär es zu heiß gewesen, aus dem hatte ich dann gar keine Zeit. Aber ja, also ich denke schon, dass das eine schöne Sache ist. Ja, aber wie gesagt, das läuft ja nicht weg. Die Wikimania findet ja jedes Jahr statt. Und im nächsten Jahr im Buenos Aires, das ist auch ein schönes Ziel. Da muss ich mal drüber nachdenken, ob ich da nicht irgendwie hin kann. Das passt für mich nächstes Jahr ganz gut, weil ich ja einen Forschungsfreisemester habe und dann da hinreisen kann.
Entschuldigung, wo war es?
In Buenos Aires.
Ja, ein anderthalb Jahr ist es her, dass wir unseren letzten Podcast gemacht haben. Seitdem hat sich einiges verändert und ich muss zugeben, dass ich die Wikipedia selbst nicht mehr so eng im Auge gehabt habe. Jetzt in der Vorbereitung sind mir überhaupt erst ein paar Sachen aufgefallen, nachdem du mich darauf hingewiesen hast. Und ich finde das jetzt auch nochmal ganz erwähnenswert. Also es gibt doch schon zahlreiche Neuigkeiten, also Features in der Wikipedia, die durchaus der Erwähnung wert sind, die jetzt nicht unbedingt alle was mit Qualitätssicherung zu tun haben. Aber grundsätzlich muss ich sagen, umso besser sich das Ding bedienen lässt, umso mehr kann sich das natürlich auch auf den Content auswirken. Vielleicht sollten wir mal so zwei, drei Sachen, von denen ich glaube, dass sie noch nicht so bekannt sind, auch erwähnen. Was, gut es gibt so Kleinigkeiten, so mit diesem Suchfeld, dass das jetzt so eine Live-Suche macht. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das immer funktioniert, aber...
Das merkt man. Da braucht man nicht groß darauf hinzuweisen, wer da was in den Suchfeld einträgt, wird merken, dass plötzlich Vorschläge kommen. Und das ist schon sehr hilfreich. Ich empfinde das auch sehr hilfreich, wenn man manchmal nicht so genau weiß, welches ist jetzt der richtige Titel. Angenommen, ich suche George Bush, wo ich unter George Walker, George W gucke. Es gibt natürlich immer Umleitungszeiten, aber es ist dann ein Klick mehr. Während wenn ich da anfange, das einzugeben, und dann ist schon die Vorauswahl da, dann bin ich schon, glaube ich, ganz gut dabei.
Macht die Sache auf jeden Fall ganz praktisch. Aber was ich, ja, was mir dann auffiel jetzt überhaupt erst, ist, dass es jetzt so eine ganze Reihe von sogenannten Helferlein sich aufgereiht haben, wenn man nämlich ein Account sich macht in der Wikipedia, was man durchaus empfehlen kann, das zu tun, damit man so bestimmte Settings hat.
Ja, und wenn man einen hat, dann werden die anderen Accounts auch automatisch mit erstellt mit Single-Login. Aber da kommen wir dann vielleicht gleich noch drauf?
Ja, das können wir auch gleich als erstes erwähnen. Also bisher war es so, dass die verschiedenen Sprachvarianten der Wikipedia alle unterschiedliche Wikis waren, die nichts miteinander zu tun hatten.
Richtig, da musste man sich jeweils in einen eigenen Account anlegen. Jetzt sagt natürlich immer gut, ich will halt nicht in vielen Sprachen indieren, das ist mir jetzt nicht so wichtig. Aber jeder, der ein bisschen mitmacht bei der Wikipedia, möchte ja schon mal bei Commons vielleicht Fotos hochladen und will auch einen Account haben.
Ja, oder wenn ich in der deutschen Wikipedia jetzt einen neuen Artikel erstelle über, was weiß ich, Erdbeer, Quark, Trotter, dann will ich ja zumindest in den Übersetzungen der anderen, also in den anderen Sprachvarianten eintragen, dass es das jetzt auch in Deutsch gibt. Dazu muss ich ja auch in die anderen Artikel reingehen. Und wenn es auch nur dieser eine Link ist, den ich dort eintrage.
Genau, da habe ich schon Interesse, auch auf andere Sprachen zu gehen. Aber wie gesagt, Wikimedia Commons ist wichtig für Bilder und Metawiki und was man auch sonst noch benutzen will, wenn man ein bisschen mehr einsteigt. Und da muss man sich immer wieder einen neuen Account anhängen. Das ist natürlich lästig. Und selbst wenn man schon einen hat, muss man sich auch immer wieder überall neu anmelden. Ich war jetzt zum Beispiel länger nicht auf der englischen Wikipedia, also muss ich mich da wieder neu anmelden. Also nicht neu anmelden, sondern einloggen und so. Das ist natürlich alles ein bisschen lästig. Und das ist jetzt vorbei, denn jetzt gibt es Single Login. Das ist also ein Verfahren, wo man seine Benutzeraccounts, die man schon mehrere hat, einfach zusammenführen kann zu einem Account. Und dann, wenn man dann einen zusammengeführten Account hat, dann ist man auch gleichzeitig, wenn man sich einmal einloggt, sozusagen überall eingeloggt. Das heißt, wenn man die andere Wikipedia aufruft, wird man da gleich automatisch, dann ist man da auch drin. Und es ist auch so, der nächste Vorteil ist, dass man, wenn man jetzt in einer neuen, in einer Wikipedia, wo man noch nicht war, sagen wir mal, ich will jetzt plötzlich auch was in der französischen mal eintragen, da irgendwie einen Link auf den deutschen Artikel, dann, wenn ich da hingehe von meiner deutschen Seite aus und ich in der deutschen eingeloggt bin, dann wird dann automatisch für mich da schon mal ein Account angelegt. Insofern das geht. Wenn natürlich dieser Name schon weg ist, geht das natürlich nicht. Aber wenn der Name noch frei ist, wird dann automatisch ein Account angelegt. Und ich brauche mich also nicht mehr, um so viele Dinge zu kümmern. Das ist natürlich eine gewisse Vereinfachung. Klar, das bringt neue Sicherheitsrisiken mit sich. Also wenn einer mal sozusagen sein Account, also das Passwort verliert, ist das sozusagen für alle. Wikipedia ist ein Problem. Auf der anderen Seite erhöht es natürlich auch die Sicherheit, weil ich nicht irgendwo ständig neu mich einloggen muss, was ja auch jedes Mal immer auch so ein gewisses Sicherheitsrisiko mit sich bringt. Und es ist eben einfach sehr viel bequemer.
Und es gibt jetzt auch einen verschlüsselten Zugang, oder?
Ja, das auch. Man kann sich bei HTTPS einloggen.
Aber das ist immer noch so separat, ne? Da muss man eine andere URL eingeben. Was war das, Secure?
Da muss ich jetzt auch nochmal nachgucken. Habe ich aber auf meiner Benutzerseite auch verlinkt. Da kann man also dann auch selber schauen, wie es geht. Ja, und was ist denn jetzt hier? Jetzt bin ich gar nicht eingeloggt.
Du bist nicht eingeloggt, oh Gott, Hilfe. Ja, bin ich eingeloggt. Aber dazu braucht man ein Login.
Ja.
Also um das zu benutzen, geht das nur für Leute mit Login oder geht das für jeden?
Naja, es ist ja sinnlos, wenn man kein Login hat. Dann kann ich mich ja nicht einloggen.
Es geht ja jetzt nur um das Einloggen mit HTTPS.
Es geht nur um das Einloggen unter HTTPS. Also was noch nicht oder ja, geht vielleicht auch, aber was auch nicht eigentlich vorgesehen ist, dass man alles unter HTTPS macht, weil natürlich das auch die Server entsprechend belastet, wenn alle Edierungen verschlüsselt sind.
Aber es gibt ja viele gute Argumente dafür. Jetzt haben wir hier gerade wieder China Olympia, da war ja auch für die Journalisten mal wieder Wikipedia abgeschaltet. Jetzt haben wir sie so ein bisschen zurückgerodert und sich gedacht, naja, jetzt müssen wir doch noch mal ein bisschen Freiheit simulieren so zwischendurch. Wikipedia darf jetzt wieder, ich weiß nicht, warum die ganzen Journalisten nicht wissen, was ein Virtual Private Network ist. Wenn die da so von einem großen Senderanschalter hingeschickt werden, warum reden sie nicht mal mit einem Techniker? Ich meine, es ist seit vielen Jahren bekannt, dass in China das Internet nicht ganz so frei ist und dass sie da auf jeden Fall eine Weile arbeiten müssen. Aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema, obwohl man auf der anderen Seite auch eigentlich dafür sein müsste, dass man in China das Internet frei zugänglich hat.
Die Jungs sind ein bisschen uneinsichtig, das ist schwierig. Wie ist denn das so mit der chinesischen Wikipedia? Da gab es ja viel Aufruhr am Anfang.
Da gibt es viel Aufruhr. Da gibt es ja auch noch ein anderes Projekt dazu. Die Chinesen wollen ja selber ihre Wikipedia machen.
Welche Chinesen jetzt? Chinesen, die sich auch aus dem Wikipedia-Umfeld herumtreiben?
Nein, nein, nein. Es gibt natürlich die chinesische Wikipedia. Die wird aber natürlich jetzt nicht aus der Volksrepublik rausgeschrieben.
Sondern nicht nur aus Hongkang und Taiwan sozusagen.
Und natürlich internationale Chinesen gibt es ja überall. Die machen natürlich da einen sich mit. Klar. Und dann gab es halt von China aus, oder gibt es immer noch eine eigene, was heißt da nicht Wikipedia? Sie haben also auch versucht, ein Internet-Lexikon da aufzubauen.
Als Alternative. Was ihren Qualitätsanforderungen entspricht sozusagen.
Genau, was die speziellen Qualitätsanforderungen der chinesischen Regierung. Aber wie gesagt, die chinesische Wikipedia gibt es. Es wäre natürlich wünschenswert, wenn die dann auch wirklich zugänglich ist aus China, wenn dort auch Leute mitarbeiten könnten, was ja jetzt nicht geht.
Ja, die Zensur-Debatte, das ist dann auch schon wieder ein neuer Podcast. Vielleicht noch mal kurz zu diesen zwei, drei Features, bevor wir auf unser Kernthema dann auch noch mehr zu sprechen kommen sollten. Es gibt so Metadaten, man kann so für Personen und alles mögliche Sachen erleben.
Da muss man sich einschalten. Also normalerweise sieht man das nicht. Es gibt aber natürlich oben, wenn man einen Wikipedia-Account hat, den Punkt Einstellungen. Und dann gibt es einen Unterpunkt Gadgets. Und wenn man da drauf geht, ich mach das mal gerade, dann kann ich das dann selber...
Dann kann man ganz viele Helferleihen einbeziehen. Da waren echt ein paar ganz praktische dabei. Ist das mit dieser Metadaten-Anzeigerei?
Ja, also fangen wir mal mit den Metadaten an. Personendaten, da kann man sich unten einblenden lassen. Ein Feld, wo Personendaten stehen, die halt im Artikel enthalten sind. Da sind also Metadaten enthalten, die man natürlich leichter auswerten kann. Insbesondere benutzt Wikipedia jetzt auch die sogenannte PND. Das ist die Personennahmendatei. Das ist eigentlich etwas, was aus dem Bibliothekswesen kommt. Denn da gibt es das Problem, dass es mehrere Personen mit gleichem Namen immer gibt. Tim Pritlove hat das Problem glaube ich nicht. Der Name ist nicht so häufig, aber mein Name ist halt relativ häufig. Und es gibt sogar neben mir noch einen Computerlinguisten gleichen Namens. Und in der Vergangenheit wurden dann schon mal seine Werke mir zugeschrieben und umgekehrt, was natürlich lästig ist. Und dank dieser Personennahmendatei ist das nicht mehr so leicht möglich. Das haben die Bibliothekare sich ausgedacht. Man ordnet einfach jeder Person eine eindeutige Nummer zu und gibt dann in der Datei auch noch so ein paar Eckdaten an, zum Beispiel das Geburtsdatum und wenn der Mensch schon tot ist, das Sterbedatum und noch ein paar andere Informationen, was er zum Beispiel macht und so. Und dann kann man Personen relativ eindeutig identifizieren. Und dann gibt es tatsächlich Leute im Bibliothekslesen, die die Werke dann auch versuchen zuzuordnen, indem sie sich die mal genauer anschauen. Und das ist manchmal nicht so ganz einfach.
Also was der BND sozusagen noch nicht durchgesetzt hat, nämlich die Einheitliche Personenkennziffer, das ist der PND bereits gelungen.
Aber wie gesagt, im Bibliothekslesen, wer also keine Bücher schreibt, der braucht sich nichts zu sagen, der wird da auch nicht erfasst. Das ist schon praktisch und das ist natürlich ganz schön, dass das auch in der Wikipedia mit drinsteckt. Denn das ist ein gutes Hilfsmittel und an diese Informationen möchte man natürlich auch drankommen. Das muss jetzt nicht für jeden sichtbar drinstecken, aber in dem entsprechenden Artikel sollte diese Nummer irgendwo drinstecken. Und dann kann man nämlich Personen wirklich eindeutig zuordnen und so. Und das ist schon wichtig. In der Wissenschaft hat das Sinn.
Na klar. Brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht weiter zu vertiefen. Ihr solltet einfach mal in euren Settings mal unter Gadgets gucken. Da gibt es so alle möglichen Sachen, die man einschalten kann, die einem dann irgendwie mehr Daten anzeigen und so weiter, dass man dann gleich Begriffsklärungsseiten auseinanderhalten kann von anderen Links etc. Und Hilfe auch für Blinde, für Screenreaderoptimierung gibt es da. Und sogar für Leute mit rot-grünen Sehschwäche gibt es eine Unterstützung.
Ja, das gibt es ja viele Leute. Ich finde das schon wichtig. Und es sind noch ein paar andere schöne Sachen. Was ich zum Beispiel praktisch finde, ist, dass der Cursor gleich schon in der Suchbox drin ist und so, wenn man das ja eigentlich will. Dann die Sache mit der Begriffsklärung, dass ich gleich schon sehe, dass es dann so rot markiert, da steht noch oben BLK dabei, dieser Link geht auf eine Begriffsklärungsseite. Ja, dann kann ich halt Navigations-Pop-Ups einbauen. Das ist sehr praktisch, wenn ich dann über einen Link gehe, steht da schon, wo es hingeht. So eine kleine Vorschau des Artikels, das ist auch hilfreich, wenn nicht einfach nur seltsame Wörter sind und ich wissen will, naja, muss ich das jetzt nachschauen, oder weiß ich vielleicht doch schon, was das ist. Dann so ein kleiner Mini-Atlas mit einer interaktiven Weltkarte für die Geokoordinaten. Denn so eine Geokoordinate, wenn man die oben hat, ist ja ganz schön und gut. Ich will auch nicht unbedingt da draufklicken und mir das bei Google Maps genau anschauen, aber ich will halt eine ungefähre Ahnung haben, wo es ist. Und da ist halt die interaktive Weltkarte einfach mal praktisch, weil ich mit der sofort was anfangen kann, während mit diesen Zahlen. Also ich weiß nicht auswendig als Nichtgeograf, wo jetzt der 59. Breitengrad oder was auch immer ist.
Ich bin schon froh, wenn ich so die Basiskoordinaten von Berlin halbwegs erinnern kann.
Jaja, und da ist es ganz schön, wenn man da gleich weiß, aha, so ungefähr da und da ist das, dann ist das doch schon ein echter Gewinn. Also ich habe sehr viele von diesen Dingen da angekreuzt, von diesen Gadgets, weil du einfach auch nicht genug davon kriegen kannst. Ja genau, das ist natürlich auch was. Dadurch wird man ja wieder motiviert und die Sache macht Spaß, weil es was Neues gibt, weil man da mal was Neues ausprobieren kann und so. Und wenn dann die Nase davon voll hat, dann macht man es halt wieder weg.
Insofern ist der Name Gadgets auch glaube ich ganz praktisch. Ich war am Anfang ein bisschen am Zweifeln. Aber kommen wir mal aufs Kernproblem. Also all diese Werkzeuge helfen natürlich dabei, die Wikipedia effektiver zu nutzen. Aber was ja schon immer eine große Debatte war und in letzter Zeit noch mehr denn je, ist halt die Frage nach der Qualität als solcher. Was macht einen Artikel gut in der Wikipedia? Und wie erhält man ihn gut? Das haben wir auch letztes Mal schon ein bisschen angesprochen. Und damals hast du ein Feature in Aussicht gestellt, die sogenannten, ich weiß nicht, ob es damals schon als Arbeitstitel so hieß, aber mittlerweile ist es unter dem Namen gesichtete Versionen bekannt.
Genau, das war damals der Arbeitstitel. Und auf Englisch ist das immer noch der Arbeitstitel, obwohl das kein richtiges Englisch ist. Cited Versions, das kann so nicht heißen. Also auf Englisch müsste man vielleicht sagen, also reviewed Versions, obwohl review eigentlich was anderes ist als dieses Dichten.
Aber es geht darum, den Inhalt eines Artikels zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt prüfen oder gegenlesen zu lassen und eine Aussage einzuholen von jemanden, der halbwegs Vertrauen genießt, der sagt, ich hab mir das angeschaut und ich kann sicherstellen, dass so die Kerninformation im Prinzip in die richtige Richtung zeigt und dass hier jetzt auch kein Schrott drin ist. Da hat sich also jetzt nicht irgendein 12-Jähriger, nachdem er aus der Schule gekommen ist, noch mal verewigt und es sind auch sonst wie keine nennenswerten Vandalismen vorgenommen worden.
Genau, also eigentlich, ja ja, eigentlich kann man die, das war ja auch vorgeschlagen als Bezeichnung für die gesichteten Versionen, nicht vandalierte Versionen, beziehungsweise non vandalized versions. Für diesen Namen hat man sich da nicht begeistern können, weil das nicht so gut klingt. Also wenn man etwas nicht vandalierte Versionen nennt, dann sieht es so aus, als sei der Normalfall, dass alles vandaliert ist. Deshalb hat man das nicht so genannt, aber das fasst das eigentlich ganz gut zusammen. Also der unbedarfte Benutzer, der vielleicht nicht angemeldet ist, sondern einfach mal schnell in die Wikipedia schauen will, der soll mit einer Version beliefert werden, die nicht vandaliert ist. Da soll jetzt nicht plötzlich bei einem Politiker eingebaut sein, dass er nebenbei ein rechtsradikaler Hitler-Attentäter war oder so. Solche Sachen sollen da eben vermieden werden. Darüber hat sich ja die Presse auch immer eschofiert. Da gab es ja immer die Journalisten, die dann eben auch mal selber sogenannte Experimente gemacht haben und dann anschließend triumphieren konnten, dass da tatsächlich kurze Zeit mal was Seltsames in der Wikipedia stand.
So nach dem Motto, ich hab da mal böses Zeug reingeschrieben und vier Wochen später war es immer noch da.
Ja, genau. Und das ist dadurch ausgeschieden, dass man eben jetzt diese Marke setzen kann. Also ich hab die Sache hier angeschaut, also Markensetzen, Flagged Revision heißt das dann. Da steht da normalerweise oben so ein kleines Icon, wenn man auf dieser Seite ist. Und da sieht man, aha, das ist gesichtet worden und damit eben nicht vandaliert. Es geht hier wirklich eigentlich nur um Vandalismus bei dieser Art der Kontrolle. Also viele verstehen das auch falsch und setzen diesen Haken nur, wenn sie sich ganz sicher sind und dann nochmal alles nachgeschaut haben. Das ist ja ganz schön und gut, führt sicherlich zu einer zusätzlichen Qualitätssteigerung. Aber eigentlich geht es nur darum, dass da kein offensichtlicher Vandalismus im Artikel ist.
Alle Leute, die uns jetzt live hören, werden natürlich jetzt sofort ans Terminal gesprungen sein und da haben wir sich mal die Wikipedia aufgerufen und werden feststellen, dass das Feature, von dem wir jetzt die ganze Zeit reden, nicht da ist. Gestern war es noch da.
Jaja, es ist schon da, aber dieses Icon oben wird jetzt im Moment nicht angezeigt, sondern ab heute kriegen alle das jetzt für eine gewisse Zeit wieder die aktuelle Version. Also man sieht daran, dass das Ganze jetzt im Testlauf ist. Die deutsche Wikipedia ist sozusagen jetzt der Testbereich, wo man das jetzt mal austestet, wie das funktioniert.
Das heißt, das gibt es derzeit auch nur in der deutschen Wikipedia?
Im Moment gibt es das nur in der deutschen Wikipedia.
Obwohl jetzt der Code von MediaWiki, der Software, die das unterstützt, ist verfügbar natürlich, könnte man überall auch entscheiden.
Das ist weil, wenn man jetzt selber ein MediaWiki aufsetzen möchte, das haben, ist das einfach einklickbar. Und es ist sogar schon mehr noch da, was noch gar nicht in Angriff genommen wurde. Wir haben jetzt über die gesichteten Versionen gesprochen, die gibt es schon, das läuft also jetzt im Testlauf.
Bevor du weitergehst, wer darf denn das machen? Weil ich sehe da nämlich nichts, wo ich sagen kann. Ich habe das jetzt hier mal durchgeguckt und ich sage, das ist okay.
Also ich sehe das bei mir. Also wenn ich in der Wikipedia angemeldet bin, sehe ich das bei mir. Und da gibt es gewisse Kriterien dazu. Also nicht jeder angemeldete Nutzer kann das, ist automatisch sichter. Sichter ist auch ein schönes Wort. So heißt das? Ja, sichter. Also nicht jeder angemeldete Nutzer ist sichter, sondern es müssen mindestens 60 Tage seit seinem ersten Edit vergangen sein. Und er muss mindestens 300 Artikel bearbeitet haben. In seiner gesamten Lebenszeit.
Egal jetzt in welchem Umfang.
Genau, er muss eine Benutzerseite haben, und er muss seine E-Mail-Adresse bestätigt haben. Das ist immer noch nicht genug. Und es muss sein Sperr-Logbuch leer sein. Das heißt, er darf nicht gesperrt worden sein. In der jüngeren Vergangenheit.
Noch mehr?
Ja, es gibt wohl noch ein paar kleinere, weitere Anforderungen.
Bis dahin trifft es auf mich noch zu. Aber ich habe trotzdem nicht das Feature an. Ich darf keinen englischen Namen haben.
Es gibt meines Wissens noch ein paar kleinere, weitere Anforderungen, die nicht so gut dokumentiert sind.
Kann man das beantragen oder kriegt man das automatisch?
Das waren die Kriterien, mit denen man das automatisch bekommt.
Das heißt, da ist einmal ein Lauf durch die Datenbank gemacht worden?
Genau. Ich habe es automatisch bekommen. Man konnte ja schon in der früheren Phase des Tests das beantragen. Das habe ich nicht gemacht, weil ich mir gedacht habe, jetzt warten wir mal ab. Denn das kann nur funktionieren, wenn es automatisch ist. Und sollte auch automatisch sein. Nach der ersten Testphase haben die Developer die Testphase in mehreren Perioden aufgeteilt. In der ersten Phase musste man sich anmelden, um das Sichterecht zu bekommen. Und jetzt geht es automatisch. Man kann aber auch noch das beantragen. Wenn man das Sichterecht aus irgendeinem Grund nicht bekommen hat, wie z.B. in deinem Fall. Wo muss ich hinfallen? Ich denke, dass es bei dir vielleicht daran liegt, dass du so lange nichts gemacht hast. Das könnte auch noch eine Rolle spielen. Da bin ich nicht ganz sicher.
Ich hatte keine Zeit.
Genau. Dann kann man sich eintragen in eine Liste. Die war eigentlich immer auch problemlos einsehbar. Ich sehe sie nur gerade nicht hier.
Also es gibt eine Liste. Man kann sich da eintragen. Okay, wir können das ja noch nachtragen in der Liste.
Wir machen das dann in der Liste. Da kann man sich dann eintragen. Dann wird man in der Regel auch freigeschaltet, wenn es nicht irgendwelche wirklich guten Gründe gibt, zum Beispiel, dass man selber Vandalismus gemacht hat.
Das heißt, wenn die Leute jetzt diese Möglichkeit haben, zu markieren, das heißt, sie markieren mit, also einfach nur so ein An und Aus. Diese aktuelle Version habe ich mir angeguckt und ich sage, die ist okay. Das kann man aber generell für alle Artikel machen. Das ist nicht so, dass man jetzt nur für bestimmte Artikel freigeschaltet ist.
Nein, das kann man für alle Artikel machen. Denn offensichtlichen Vandalismus kann jeder erkennen. Das ist eigentlich keine besondere Schwierigkeit.
Gut, aber es geht ja über den Vandalismus hinaus. Es geht ja eigentlich auch um so eine... Ja, das ist die Frage. Geht das auch?
Nein, nein, bei den gesichteten Versionen geht es nur um Vandalismus. Offensichtlichen Vandalismus. Jetzt gibt es noch eine zweite Stufe, die ist auch schon implementiert, aber das macht man noch nicht. Das sind die sogenannten geprüften Versionen. Das sind eigentlich die, die dann Reviewed Versions heißen sollen. Verstehe. Da geht es wirklich darum, ein Review, also eine Beurteilung der Version zu machen. Dann kann man auch ein Fähnchen setzen und dann soll man sogar auf der Diskussionsseite nochmal angeben, was man von dem Artikel hält. Aber da ist natürlich das Problem, dass man zum Prüfen auch Leute haben muss, die das wirklich prüfen können, also wirklich beurteilen können. Das heißt, man braucht Fachleute. Und die Community ist sich noch nicht so ganz sicher, wie man jetzt an diese Fachleute kommen soll. Da gibt es verschiedene Modelle, die da gegenüberstehen. Kann man auch sehen. Also ich hatte ja vorhin schon gesagt, es gibt die Seite, die Informationen gibt über die gesichteten Versionen, also Wikipedia gesichtete Version, Wikipedia doppelpunkt gesichtete Version und es gibt natürlich auch noch Wikipedia doppelpunkt geprüfte Version. Da sind auch die verschiedenen Modelle verlinkt, wie man an die Prüfer kommen will. Da gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass man tatsächlich auf die Suche nach Fachleuten geht. Da gibt es die andere Möglichkeit, dass Leute aus der Community selber vorschlagen als Fachleute, dann darüber abgestimmt wird und so, so ähnlich wie man das auch mit exzellenten Artikeln macht. Dass dann ein Meinungsbild gebildet wird, und dann ist jemand Fachmann oder Fachfrau. Dann kann man das natürlich mit den Portalen verknüpfen. Da gibt es ganz verschiedene Möglichkeiten, die diskutiert werden im Augenblick. Aber da es so viele Möglichkeiten gibt, ist man da noch zu keiner Entscheidung gekommen.
Wie lange läuft der Test schon?
Der Test mit den gesichteten Versionen? Der hat angefangen Anfang des Jahres, allerdings nicht sofort in der ersten Phase. Das war schon letztes Jahr. Entschuldigung, der Test in dem Sandkasten-Wiki hat im letzten Jahr angefangen. Irgendwann in der zweiten Jahreshefte. Dann hat man es freigeschaltet im Frühjahr dieses Jahres, dass es richtig in der Wikipedia läuft. Da gab es zunächst noch mal zwei Versionen. Da musste man noch gucken mit dem Layout, ob alles klappt. Ab April ist es wirklich in der Wikipedia. Es steht aber alles auf der Seite über die gesichtete Version. Seither lief es auch mit dem Icon oben. Tatsächlich bekam man als nicht angemeldeter Benutzer erst mal nur die neueste gesichtete Version zu sehen. Jetzt ist es gerade wieder anders eingeschaltet worden. Da war ich auch etwas überrascht.
Wahrscheinlich ist es einfach mal zu gucken, wie groß der Entzug ist.
Ja genau, wie gesagt, es war in der Testphase vorgesehen, dass man das auch nochmal wieder abschaltet, um den Unterschied zu sehen. Aber es kam jetzt auch für mich ein bisschen überraschend. Und jetzt soll man auch Erfahrungsberichte abgeben, und dann wird das also evaluiert. Man kann auch jetzt schon, wenn man auf die Seite wikipedia.com gesichtete Versionen geht, ist unten so ein Link auf Statistik. Und da kann man sehr schön sehen, wie die Sache sich entwickelt. Moment, ich muss gerade mal gucken, wo ich das hier habe.
Auf die Statistik von was?
Von den gesichteten Versionen hier, sehe ich gerade. Also von den 795.870 Artikeln der deutschsprachigen Wikipedia besitzen 523.568, mindestens eine gesichtete Version. Das sind 65,79 Prozent.
65 Prozent aller Wikipedia-Artikel sind gesichtet?
Ja.
Oh, das ist viel mehr als ich erwartet hätte.
Ja, genau. Und was auch interessant ist, ist, dass bei 517.777, also bei einer halben Million Artikel, die neueste Version als gesichtet markiert ist. Das ist natürlich wichtig, ob das die neueste Version ist oder wie alt die gesichtete Version ist. Denn wenn die zu alt ist, wird das irgendwann auch nicht mehr sinnvoll. Das sind auch wieder 65 Prozent. Also auch eigentlich eine recht gute Zahl. Also das ist schon, das zeigt eigentlich, dass es relativ gut funktioniert.
Gibt es auch so eine Relation, so eine Statistik, die das so in Verhältnis setzt zu der Popularität der Artikel?
Nee, das gibt es glaube ich noch nicht. Also da müsste man noch mal schauen. Aber was man zum Beispiel machen kann, das ist auch auf der Seite gesichtete Versionen eingestellt. Man kann sich zum Beispiel eine Liste anzeigen lassen, innerhalb von Kategorien von Artikeln, welche Sachen gerade nicht gesichtet sind oder welche man vielleicht mal sichten könnte, zum Beispiel wenn man selber Spezialist ist. Das ist eigentlich ein Punkt, der dann für die geprüften Versionen interessant wird.
Noch wichtiger wird so. Aber man prüft natürlich auch lieber Sachen, die einem auch was sagen, weil sonst schaltet man ja nach der Hälfte des Artikels ab.
Genau. Also man sieht, es funktioniert. Man kann es unterschiedlich bewerten. Hier steht in der Statistik, dass wenn mit dem gleichen Rhythmus weiter gesichtet wird, dass dann am 19.9.2008, also in 46 Tagen, alle Artikel mindestens einmal gesichtet worden sind. Das klingt eigentlich schon ganz gut.
Welche Artikel haben wir denn jetzt in der Wikipedia?
Ja, sagt ich ja. In der Deutschen 795.870.
Wow, also finde ich schon mal ganz gutes Ergebnis. Das heißt, das Ganze läuft seit ein paar Monaten. Wir sind im Prinzip in der ersten Stufe gesichtet. Das heißt, er hat erst mal das Schlimmste verändert. Was in dem Moment, wo man sagen kann, das funktioniert auch. Wenn ich mir die Zahlen jetzt so anhöre, würde ich sagen, das kann ganz gut greifen. Vor allem, wenn wirklich ein Artikel in der Diskussion ist, dann kann man zumindest sehen, aha, ist nicht gesichtet worden. Man müsste sozusagen in der öffentlichen Diskussion mal unterscheiden, wie viel regt man sich jetzt noch über gesichtete Versionen auf im Verhältnis zu den ungesichteten. Und später natürlich dann auch bei den geprüften Versionen, was ich natürlich noch mal interessant finde.
Das wird noch interessant. Ich kann vielleicht noch zu den Gesichteten sagen. Also die hebräische Wikipedia denkt gerade darüber nach, also die Leute, die die machen, denkt gerade darüber nach, das auch zu übernehmen, den gesichteten Versionen. Weil natürlich bei der hebräischen Wikipedia auch Vandalismus noch mal eine ganz besondere Kategorie darstellt. Und auch gerade dieser Vandalismus, der als großes Problem angesehen wird, nämlich der subtile Vandalismus. Wenn ich da einfach was lösche oder reinschreibe, Peter ist doof oder so, das fällt natürlich relativ schnell auf. Wenn ich subtil vandaliere, kann es wirklich dazu kommen, dass tatsächlich Fehlinformationen oder eben...
So Zwischentöne.
Zwischentöne lange drin bleiben. Und das ist natürlich ärgerlich. Bestimmte Wikipedias leiden da mehr oder weniger darunter. Das hängt auch damit zusammen, wie groß die Community ist. Bei der deutschen Wikipedia ist die Community sehr groß. Da sind sowieso viele Augen, die drauf schauen. Bei anderen Sprachen ist die Community nicht so groß. Dafür aber auch der Druck durch Vandalen groß. Die hebräischen Wikipedia ist ein Beispiel. Die wollen das auch gerne einführen.
Wie ist denn die Erwartungshaltung an die Leute, die jetzt was sichten? Was sind die Anforderungen für den Sichtprozess als Seuchen?
Wir haben ja schon gehört, mindestens so und so viele Tage dabei.
Nicht, dass man zugelassen wird, sondern in dem Moment, wo ich es mache. Ich gehe jetzt los und will eine Seite sichten. Gibt es da jetzt auch schon formulierte Regeln oder Empfehlungen?
Du solltest durchgucken, ob offensichtlicher Vandalismus da nicht vorhanden ist. Die Leute sind meistens etwas kritischer. Das sehe ich auch an mir selber, wenn ich jetzt was sichte. Da sind jetzt irgendwie nicht die richtigen Anführungszeichen drin. Typografisch korrekt. Dann muss ich das immer erst korrektieren, obwohl das beim Sichten eigentlich nicht vorgesehen ist. Da geht es nur darum, dass kein offensichtlicher Vandalismus drin ist. Das geht eigentlich relativ schnell. Ich muss den Artikel nur einmal durchlesen. Und wenn ich den Eindruck habe, dass es nicht vandaliert, dann mache ich da mein Häkchen.
Und wenn ich den Eindruck habe, dass es vandaliert wurde?
Dann mache ich das Häkchen nicht.
Macht man ein Häkchen nicht oder macht man ein Nicht-Häkchen? Also sagt man, diese Version lässt sich nicht sichten? Dann müssen sich andere darauf stürzen?
Dann soll man den offensichtlichen Vandalismus erstmal wegmachen.
Gut, wenn man ihn findet, muss man ihn auch wegmachen. Ist ja eigentlich klar.
Es gibt schon so Fälle bei Seiten, wo ich gesagt habe, oh, das ist aber alles komisch formuliert, da muss doch noch mal einer ran, da habe ich den Haken nicht gesetzt. Dann habe ich aber dummerweise auch nicht einen Baustein reingesetzt. Und ich habe dummerweise auch nicht das in der Diskussionsseite geschrieben. Das sollte man natürlich tun. Nur manchmal ist halt die Zeit knapp und so. Also da gibt es schon unterschiedliche Gründe, warum ich mir die Wikipedia anschaue. Und wenn ich mir irgendwie Informationen besorge und sehe, die Seite ist aber gut, dann kann ich gleich mal ein Häkchen setzen. Wenn ich sehe, die Seite ist nicht so gut, dann setze ich das Häkchen halt nicht, aber mach auch nichts.
Vielleicht mal so ein bisschen allgemeiner die Frage nach der Qualität gestellt. Ich meine, Vandalismus, das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich das Offensichtliche. Und ich denke, was aber eigentlich immer mitschwebt, wenn die Leute die Qualität der Wikipedia kritisieren, ist natürlich dieses, kann ich mich auf diese Informationen eigentlich wirklich verlassen? Oder ist das nicht irgendwie alles nur dahergeschrieben? Es gab viele Auseinandersetzungen. Ich meine, bekannt jetzt neben dem reinen Vandalismus sind halt auch so diese Edit Wars, wenn Leute sich auf Artikel stürzen und dann gegenseitig versuchen, sich da irgendwie die Argumente unterzuschieben oder wegzunehmen. Wie hat sich denn das entwickelt? So, also innerhalb der Wikipedia. Insbesondere vielleicht noch mit diesem Hinblick auf diese ganzen Löschkriege, was in meiner Sichtweise in letzter Zeit so das auffälligste Problem war. Weil viele Artikel gibt es jetzt irgendwie schon. Man ist einfach raus aus dieser Geburtsphase, dass einfach noch die Hälfte fehlt. Jetzt gibt es eigentlich eine erschlagende Menge an Begriffen. Ich habe mir schon lange nicht mehr gelungen, irgendwas zu finden, was wirklich substanziell gefehlt hat. Dann kommt aber dann sofort einer, wenn man doch mal was Neues anlegt und sagt, das ist aber jetzt nicht relevant. Die Tür ist zu hier, hier kommt jetzt keiner mehr rein.
Ja, genau. Das ist leider etwas, was aus meiner Sicht ein bisschen überhand genommen hat, dass es viele Leute gibt, die da löschen, dass tatsächlich solche Löschkriege stattfinden, wo dann mit der Relevanzkeule gearbeitet wird. Da wird gesagt, das ist nicht relevant, das ist nicht enzyklopädisch, das muss raus. Und da kann man sich natürlich schon streiten. Es gibt, wie gesagt, immer noch die beiden großen Gruppen, die Includisten und die Excludisten. Und jetzt in der Frage der Relevanzdiskussion sind natürlich die Excludisten sehr engagiert und löschen dann gerne etwas. Und wie gesagt, das ist problematisch. Es gibt eben auch die Seite Wikipedia Relevanzkriterien, die wächst und wächst und wächst. Und dadurch ist natürlich es sehr leicht, irgendwelche Sachen rauszukegeln. Also ich selber hab das mitbekommen vor einem halben Jahr. Da ging es um einen Bereich, der mich etwas interessiert. Also Plansprachen. Da gibt es natürlich unheimlich viele Plansprachen. Also Sprachen, die erfunden worden sind, so wie Esperanto, aber da gibt es halt viele. Und da gibt es natürlich viele, von denen man wenig gehört hat. Dies aber gibt. Also wo es mal solche Projekte gab. Also außer Esperanto sind ja Plansprachen nicht so sehr in Gebrauch. Und da gibt es natürlich viele unbekannte oder weniger bekannte Projekte, die in der Wikipedia zu finden sind. Und da gab es eben einige Leute, die meinten, das sei ja irrelevant. Da sollte man mal aufräumen und die ganzen, diese Projekte löschen. Und das war dann schon problematisch. Dann hieß es, dann wurde plötzlich ein Relevanzkriterium aufgenommen, was ich an sich für problematisch halte, nämlich da hieß es, die Relevanz muss aus dem Artikel hervorgehen. Das ist natürlich schwierig. Also, wenn wir mal die Plansprachen nehmen, da gibt es ein paar Plansprachen, die man sicherlich auch immer wieder findet in Kreuzverdrehungen wie Ido oder Interlingua oder so. Aber Ido hat vielleicht 50 Sprecher, ich weiß es nicht genau, ganz wenige Sprecher. Interlingua ist praktisch auch mit ganz wenigen Sprechern. Dann ist halt die Frage wirklich, wie macht man da die Relevanz fest? Man müsste, wenn man dieses Relevanzkriterium erfüllen will, müsste man irgendwie oben noch reinschreiben, kommt in oft dem Kreuzverdrehungsrätsel vor oder so. Aber eigentlich ist das nicht Sinn der Wikipedia, solche Dinge da reinzuschreiben. Also das ist ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man wirklich fordert, dass die Relevanz von Dingen aus dem Artikel hervorgehen muss. Aber das ist nun mal als Relevanzkriterium dann aufgestellt worden, und das ist dann oft als Leschkeule benutzt worden. Ich bin halt bekennender Inkludist. Ich möchte halt wirklich auch alles solche Dinge finden. Auch noch sehr entlegene Plansprachen sollten natürlich auch in der Wikipedia verzeichnet sein. Und da gibt es eben eine andere Meinung. Da ist eben viel gestritten worden. Also wie gesagt, sehr mit harten Bandagen in diesem Bereich Plansprachen, der mich halt interessiert. In vielen anderen Bereichen auch. Da habe ich natürlich dann weniger mitbekommen, weil nicht alles Bereiche sind, die mich halt sehr interessieren. Also das ist schon eine schwierige Frage. Und ich glaube, das wird noch einige Zeit dauern. Ich habe aber die Hoffnung, dass wenn die Zahl der Regeln und auch der Relevanzkriterien eine gewisse Anzahl überschreitet, dann wird es so kompliziert, dass sich dann doch keiner mehr dran hält. Und so sind dann die Relevanzkriterien oder die Regeln ausgehebelt worden. Bei der Wikipedia haben wir wirklich eine Zunahme von Regeln, immer mehr Regeln. Und irgendwann sind es halt so viele Regeln, dass es so unübersichtlich wird, dass die Leute doch wieder machen, was sie wollen. Und es ist dann wieder besonders leicht, Regeln zu ignorieren und so eben auch die Relevanzkriterien zu ignorieren. Also, ich denke...
Hast du denn schon mal einen Artikel zur Löschung vorgeschlagen?
Ich bin gar nicht Administrator. Also, man kann mich natürlich sperren, klar. Aber für nichts tun, gesperrt zu werden, das wäre ganz neu. Aber das kommt auch noch.
Wie ist denn da so die psychische Gemengelage? Wie kann man denn das einschätzen? Viele Leute sind dann abgestoßen davon, ich hab jetzt mal in die Liste der Löschkandidaten geschaut, heute prompt eine Person, die ich tatsächlich auch kenne, zwar nicht besonders gut kenne, aber wo ich schon weiß, alles klar ist, eine Person, die hat relativ viel in der öffentlichen Kunstszene gemacht. Und auch hier klebt gleich wieder ein Löschantrag dran, mit Begründung, Relevanz im Einleitungssatz nicht zu erkennen. Darunter sind allerdings ganz lange Listen, wo diese Künstlerin irgendwie gearbeitet hat und gewirkt hat. Was soll das?
Ja, das ist in der Tat problematisch. Ich wäre ja dann für beibehalten, aber gewisse Leute meinen, das ginge nicht, das sei nicht enzyklopädisch genug. Man müsste irgendwie einschränken, was in die Wikipedia gehört, obwohl der Speicherplatz ja wirklich virtuell unendlich ist. Da müsste man eigentlich keine Angst davor haben. Es ist für mich wirklich schwer nachzuvollziehen, was die Leute da reitet. Ich meine, die englische Wikipedia ist da sehr viel flexibler. Und da gibt es sicherlich Seiten, die kein Mensch anschauen will. Und ich denke, man kann sich so eine gewisse Freiheit auch vielleicht in der deutschen Wikipedia erlauben. Und da ist halt immer wieder das Problem, dass ich glaube, das hängt mit der Mentalität auch zusammen in Deutschland. Man möchte halt gerne klare Regeln haben. Dann gibt es immer diese Sache, dass man Angst davor hat, dass irgendwelche Journalisten behaupten, dass so und so viel Prozent der Wikipedia-Artikel irgendwie irrelevant sein. Und so kommt das dann, dass die Leute da was löschen wollen. Also ich finde, man sollte da wirklich sehr flexibel sein. Man hat zum Beispiel gerade gesagt, gut, es muss nicht jeder... Also früher war es ja so, dass eben auch Wissenschaftler, wenn sie halt irgendwelche Qualifikationsarbeiten abgeschlossen hatten, dann auch aufgenommen wurden. Und jetzt muss eben dann auch noch klar sein, dass die wirklich im Wissenschaftsbetrieb tätig sind oder waren. Und damit sie relevant sind. Das ist wirklich dann eine Abwägungssache, wo ich das Gefühl habe, dass man in Deutschland einfach zu sehr da auf Relevanz pocht. Das muss einfach nicht sein.
Wie machen denn das andere Enzyklopädie? Die Wikipedia ist natürlich nun mit Abstand das meistgenutzte und, denke ich, auch populärste Enzyklopädie-Ding. Nicht nur im Internet, sondern ich denke, die Wikipedia hat mittlerweile auch alles überholt, was bisher so als Standardgeil ist. Wer redet jetzt noch vom Brockhaus? Irgendwie keiner. Auch der Spiegel schreibt nicht, was der Brockhaus über irgendetwas sagt, sondern was die Wikipedia da darüber sagt, weil sie einfach wissen, ein Brockhaus, das wissen halt viele Jahre alt und alles mit Abkürzungen. Und in der Wikipedia ist es halt so aktuell, dass wenn irgendwie von jemandem, der tot bekanntgeben wird, dann kann man einfach darauf wetten, dass es einfach 30 Sekunden später in diesem Artikel steht.
Naja, also da ist ja schon, manchmal steht es ja in der Wikipedia schneller als der Betroffene.
Da hast du schon vor seinem Versterben.
Naja, es gibt manchmal, es gibt schon sehr, sehr, es gibt so ein paar Anekdoten halt, dass so Leute...
Tod gestimmt wurden.
Naja, wir hatten das damals beim Papst. Da wollten so und so viele Leute die Ersten sein, die den Tod des Papstes anzeigen. Dann ist die Seite halt dann irgendwann gesperrt worden. Und erst Minuten nach der allgemeinen Bekanntgabe des Todes dann da eingetragen worden. Und es gab kürzlich so einen Fall von einem amerikanischen Journalisten, der, ich glaube ein Fernsehjournalist von CBS, der da irgendwie im Studio gestorben ist. Und da hat man das sofort in die Wikipedia eingetragen, wo irgendjemand da bei dem Rundfunksender nichts Besseres zu tun hatte. Der Notarzt wird wahrscheinlich schon da gewesen sein, das in die Wikipedia einzutragen, sodass da wirklich die Wikipedia wenige Sekunden nach dem Ableben desjenigen...
Der ist umgekippt. Bevor die Leute sich um Erste Hilfe gekümmert haben, haben sie es erstmal in die Wikipedia eingetragen.
In dem Studio waren halt viele Leute und es ist Erste Hilfe geleistet worden. Einer hat sofort das eingetragen. Also das ist schon erstaunlich.
Oh je, oh Gott, ich seh schon in röchelnden Prominenten vor mir auf der Straße bluten und dann so Moment, ich kann dir noch nicht helfen, ich muss hier noch kurz den Edit abschließen.
Auf ein Feier.
Na gut, ganz brutal ist, glaube ich, die Worte der Wikipedia. Aber wie immer wollte ich auch was anderes raus. Es gibt ja jetzt ein neues Projekt von unser allerliebster Suchmaschine, Google. Mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar, wie sie sich da eigentlich präsentieren. Das Projekt heißt, wie heißt es denn jetzt eigentlich?
Knol.
Oder Knol.
Ich finde, man sollte das Deutsch aussprechen, wenn man auf Deutsch spricht. Knol finde ich einfach schöner als Knol. Also Knol klingt so nach nichts, aber Knol. Aber ich finde es schöner. Ich finde Knol schöner.
Knol findest du schön? Knol?
Knol? Von mir aus Knol. Aber mit dem K würde ich es auf Deutsch aussprechen. Auf Englisch natürlich nicht.
Du hast ja ein Knol.
Ich sag ja auch Psycho auf Deutsch. Was ist das?
Also Knol ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was Google da geritten hat, aber als sie das veröffentlicht haben, ich dachte, ich guck nicht richtig. Das sah erstmal so ein bisschen aus wie so eine Gesundheitsinformationsbroschüre. Ja, also man...
Stimmt, Gesundheitsartikel sind da sehr zahlreich, ja.
Ja, was mir schon mal so das erste Fragezeichen ins Gesicht gesetzt hat. Ich mein, ich weiß, dass Google, was heißt ich weiß, man weiß, dass Google erhebliche Investitionen im Bereich der Genetikforschung hat, dass sie jetzt drauf und dran sind auch diesen, oh Gott, korrigiere ich mich, jetzt weiß ich es gar nicht so ganz genau, sie wollten im medizinischen Bereich die Personen in den USA sozusagen so eine Gesundheitsakte auch führen, so einen Dienst einzuführen. Also das ist sozusagen großes Business in den USA und Google positioniert sich da. Jetzt kommen sie halt mit ihrem Knol oder wie es auch immer heißen mag und 90 Prozent der Artikel, die auf dieser Startseite da gefeatured sind in einer merkwürdigen Reihenfolge, beschäftigen sich halt einfach mit Krankheiten oder Medizinern. Gut, aber unabhängig davon, hast du schon eine Vorstellung davon, was Google da jetzt eigentlich gerade produziert?
Sie produzieren schon freies Wissen. Das ist schon mal erstmal eine Sache, die ich begrüßen würde.
Freies Wissen im Sinne von?
Na ja, es gibt Informationen dort, die frei zur Verfügung stehen. Also die Standardlizenz bzw. defaultmäßig steht das alles unter CC BY, also Creative Commons Lizenz, und zwar der offensten Creative Commons Lizenz. Nämlich muss nur der Autor genannt werden. Und das finde ich eigentlich sehr gut. Ich halte diese Lizenz sowieso für die beste. Also es ist mit Sicherheit der Wikipedia-Lizenz, also der der GFDL, der Knol Free Documentation License, überlegen, weil dieser ganze ungeheure Rattenschwanz der GFDL wegfällt, denn die ist ja nicht frei. Ich kann im Grunde die Sachen der Wikipedia, also ich hab ein Buch geschrieben im letzten Jahr und wollte natürlich gerne auch ein bisschen was so aus Wikipedia reinholen, Karten und so. Also es gibt die italienische Sprachwissenschaft, nur wenn man natürlich Karten von Italien oder so drin haben. Ja, findet man unheimlich viel in Wikipedia Commons und so, aber meistens unter der falschen Lizenz. Also musste ich hergehen und Karten selber zeichnen.
Was heißt unter der falschen Lizenz?
Na ja, unter GFDL.
Ja, was ist daran falsch?
Das kann man nicht machen. Also ich kann das dem Verlag nicht beibringen, dass man dann bei jeder Karte dabeischreibt, GFDL, die wichtigsten Autoren, die an der Karte mitgewirkt haben, das ist ja nun kollaborativ auch gemacht worden, da aufhört und hinten auf Englisch vier Seiten GFDL reinmacht. Das hätte der Verlag nicht geschluckt. Also das ist einfach nicht handhabbar. Gut, bei einem Buch kann man das vielleicht noch machen. Aber bei einer Zeitung stellen wir vor, da will jemand ein Diagramm in der Zeitung veröffentlichen. Da nimmt man lieber irgendwas von Google, wo man dann draufschreibt, Copyright Google oder so, als dass man dann hinterher in der Zeitung als Anhang noch die GFDL mit reindruckt.
Gab es da nicht zu dieser Problematik schon so den Beschluss, dass man das auch irgendwie einfacher machen kann, dass man da irgendwie einen Link setzt und damit ist es auch gut?
Ja, gut, ein Link. Das ist ja noch im Stritten, ob man das kann. Also eigentlich muss die GFDL mit veröffentlicht werden bei Veröffentlichungen von GFDL-Texten. Also es macht die Sache schon schwierig. Und auch das mit den wichtigsten Autoren ist halt ein gewisses Problem.
Ja, wichtigsten Autoren. Eigentlich ja alle.
Eigentlich ja alle. Man hat sich ja schon da, weil es nicht geht, in einem Wiki kann man nicht alle.
Ja, ich stehe dann sozusagen in jedem Artikel auch mit, als Autor, wo ich mal ein Komma korrigiert habe sozusagen.
Genau, das war ja das Schöne bei den Wikibooks. Ich habe dann immer geguckt hinten bei den Autoren und da taucht bei den komischsten Themen auf, wo ich gar nicht wusste, dass ich dazu mal was geschrieben habe. Also das ist schon alles ein bisschen grenzfertig mit der GFDR. Also CC BY ist schon toll. Und ich finde, CC BY ist auch der Public Domain überlegen, obwohl man ja sagt, die Freiste ist, wenn alles Public Domain ist. Aber ich finde es schon wichtig, wenn ich Informationen beurteilen will, dass ich weiß, von wem die kommen. Also da irgendwie noch den Autor anzugeben, das kann schon sehr nützlich sein.
Aber wie macht denn jetzt die Knol?
Gut, die Knol macht das so, dass sie also bei den Lizenzen defaultmäßig CC BY hat. Man kann aber auch bei Knol andere Lizenzen angeben, wenn man will und sogar All Rights Reserved machen.
Und wie wird man da Autor?
Ja, kommen wir gleich drauf. Erstmal noch zu den Lizenzen, das kann man schnell abschließen. Dazu kommt noch eine sehr problematische Sache. Die Sachen sind alle doppel lizenziert. Nämlich Google nimmt sich selbst das Recht raus, alles nach Gutdünken für ihre Zwecke benutzen zu dürfen. Und das ist natürlich schon problematisch, diese Doppel-Lizenzierung.
Ja, aber was ist da noch anders? Ich meine, wenn das CC BY ist...
Ja gut, nee, nee. Es ist frei, aber...
Ich meine, was kann Google dann tun, was andere nicht tun können?
Ja, Google kann auch ohne Nennung der Autoren was machen.
Ah.
Also gut, aber lassen wir das, das ist eine spezielle Problematik. Ich bin auch nicht so ein Jurist. Also lassen wir die andere Frage, was eigentlich interessant ist, wie wird man der Autor, was wird da geschrieben und so weiter.
Genau, und wie machen die das mit der Qualität?
Was ist zum Beispiel auch der Unterschied zwischen Wikipedia und Knol? Also erstmal, der große Unterschied ist, dass da Einzelautoren im Vordergrund stehen. Also ich bin jemand, der was weiß über ein Thema. Sagen wir mal, was hab ich mir hier mal ausgesucht. Über minimalinvasive Verfahren in der Herzchirurgie. Dann schreib ich halt einen Artikel darüber, weil ich mich da auskenne. Da ist dann auch mein Bild daneben. Da steht dann auch, dass ich vielleicht Herzchirurg bin. Und dann sieht man, aha, ich könnte wirklich noch von der Sache haben. Und dann schreib ich dann meinen Artikel. Und dieser Artikel kann dann bewertet werden. Eigentlich alle Google-Nutzer, die Google-Countdown, die können das bewerten. Dann sieht man gleich so Sternchen, aha, der Artikel ist wohl gut oder weniger gut. Und man kann nicht nur bewerten, sondern man kann auch Veränderungen vorschlagen. Aber man kann es eben nur vorschlagen, der Hauptautor bleibt eben derjenige, der bestimmt, was da drin steht.
Das heißt, es kann zu einem Artikel, zu einem Thema auch mehrere Artikel geben?
Genau. Und da sieht man schon, so richtig kollaborativ ist es nicht. Wenn man jetzt mal was nimmt, wo viele Leute sich zu äußern wollen, zum Beispiel Barack Obama, da gibt es natürlich nicht einen Artikel über Barack Obama, sondern verschiedene Artikel. Da gibt es dann auch Artikel, die heißen Biography of Barack Obama oder so. Da muss man sich dann eventuell alles durchlesen, wenn man wirklich umfassend informiert sein möchte. Also man liest sich das, durch was die höchste Bewertung hat. Kann man natürlich auch. Was auch immer das mit der höchsten Bewertung heißt. Das muss ja nicht sein, dass das der ausgewogenste Artikel ist, sondern es ist vielleicht der Artikel, der sich so ein bisschen auch, wo halt viele Sympathisanten so geklickt haben oder viele Gegner so geklickt haben. Also das ist natürlich ein bisschen problematisch. Aber man sieht hier schon einen ganz wichtigen Unterschied, der immer übersehen wird. Weil ich darf immer sagen, Knol, das ist so wie die Wikipedia. Also zwei wichtige Unterschiede muss man halt einfach mal sehen. Es ist nicht wirklich kollaborativ, sondern es sind schon Einzelpersonen, die im Vordergrund stehen. Das ist wirklich was anderes als kollaboratives Wissen. Und damit verbunden sind es auch andere Themen. Also ich könnte in der Wikipedia keinen Artikel veröffentlichen mit der Bezeichnung minimalinvasive Verfahren in der Herzchirurgie. Es gibt natürlich einen Artikel Herzchirurgie, also Heart Surgery oder so. Das gibt's. Und der Artikel ist kollaborativ erstellt. Aber bei Knol ist es eigentlich immer ein spezielles Thema. Ist ja klar, wenn ein Autor was schreibt, der kann nicht alle Aspekte der Heart Surgery abdecken. Denn wenn jemand Chirurg ist, dann wird er sich die Geschichte der Herzchirurgie vielleicht nicht gerade so gut erarbeitet haben. Da müssen dann andere ran. Das ist schon nochmal ein Unterschied. Es ist eine ganz andere Art von Artikeln. Das sind eigentlich ganz spezifische Artikel, die in Knol den Vorteil haben und die in der Wikipedia so gar nicht reinpassen. Für mich, jetzt für mein Fach gesehen, ich könnte da einen Artikel veröffentlichen über die Grammatikalisierung von Höflichkeit oder so. Das ginge in der Wikipedia nicht, weil man da vielleicht einen Artikel hat über Grammatik oder Höflichkeit, aber nicht zusammen. Das könnte ich aber bei Knol machen.
Weil das kein stehender Begriff ist, sozusagen.
Ja, genau. Aber das wäre dann eben auch mein Thema.
Und wäre das auch für dich interessant, das bei Knol zu veröffentlichen?
Ja, das wollte ich eigentlich mal machen. Das war jetzt eigentlich mein Projekt für diesen Sommer.
Und was ist jetzt deine Motivation, das dann da zu tun? Ist das so wie ein Paperschreiben?
Ja, genau, das ist wie ein Paperschreiben, aber populär wissenschaftlich. Ein wissenschaftliches Paper ist natürlich was anderes, das ist halt wirklich für ein Fachpublikum. Und hier würde ich mal so was für ein Line-Publikum schreiben, einfach mal zu sehen, was das gibt. Höflichkeit ist ein Thema, das viele interessiert. Höflichkeit in der Grammatik, das könnte interessant sein. Und dann kriege ich vielleicht Feedback, ich weiß es nicht. Also es ist einfach nur für mich ein Test. Die Motivation ist jetzt, weil es neu ist. Und weil ich das ausprobieren will.
Denkst du, dass es mit den Lizenzen überhaupt geht, aus Knol zu übernehmen, in die Wikipedia?
Nee, eigentlich geht das nicht im Moment. Denn die Lizenzen sind ja nicht kompatibel. Also wenn ich einen Artikel schreibe, bei Knol und ihm, das sind die Wikipedia, kann ich das machen. Aber wenn jemand anders das tut, das geht eigentlich nicht. Da müsste er schon den Autor irgendwie um Zustimmung bitten. Denn sonst ist es die CC-Beilizenz und die ist nicht kompatibel mit der Wikipedia. Also das kann man nicht einfach nehmen, in die Wikipedia reintun, wo steht dann der Autor? Als Zitat vielleicht, aber sonst muss ja der Autor irgendwie rein.
Gibt es bei Knol nicht auch die Möglichkeit, Geld zu verdienen? Dass man bezahlt wird für Artikel?
Google macht da irgendwie Ads, aber dass man bezahlt wird, das ist mir neu.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht als Information hier reinwerfen, sondern nur als Gerüchte, Echo, was ich gerade im Kopf habe.
Ne, also das ist mir neu. Da müsste man noch mal gucken. Würde mich jetzt nicht überraschen.
Knol ist noch sehr neu, muss man dazu sagen. Das gibt es jetzt gerade mal seit, ja, was weiß ich, 23. Juli. Also das ist jetzt keine zwei Wochen alt und muss noch mal beobachtet werden.
Also ich meine, was auch natürlich ein wichtiger Aspekt ist, ist natürlich, dass Knol zu Google gehört und damit natürlich an sich schon hoch gerankt wird. Ich meine, das ist Google und Google ist natürlich, präferiert natürlich Google bei Suchen und so weiter. Also das ist natürlich auch ein Punkt, warum jemand vielleicht da was schreiben will, weil er mit seiner Information sehr schnell sehr viele Leute erreicht. Das ist schon ein interessanter Punkt. Und ich glaube, dass Google hier auch da spekuliert drauf, dass das viele Leute interessieren könnte. Und das ist vielleicht auch der Grund, warum so viele Mediziner da schreiben. Ich kann es mir nur vorstellen. Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber bei Medizinern geht es ja bei der Karriere auch immer um sogenannten Impact-Faktoren und so. Und ich glaube, dass man bei Google da gut bedient wird, seine eigenen Arbeiten da entsprechend publik zu machen, um dann eben auch entsprechende Reputationen zu bekommen, dadurch, dass die Leute dann auf die Artikel zugreifen und die Artikel einen hohen Impact bekommen. Also ich glaube, dass das wirklich erklärt, warum jetzt die Mediziner da so besonders aktiv sind.
Ich sehe übrigens gerade, es ist nicht nur möglich, halt mit CCC-Buy-Lizenz zu arbeiten, sondern auch mit Non-Commercial oder eben auch richtig All-Rice Reserved.
Genau, All-Rice Reserved oder eben so Zwischenstellungen Non-Commercial.
Hast du schon gesagt.
Wobei Non-Commercial, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist eine problematische Lizenz, weil niemand so genau weiß, was eigentlich Non-Commercial ist.
Da bricht sich die Musik ja schon seit längerer Zeit, die Zähne dran aus.
Ja, also das ist ein ganz großes Problem. Also da würde ich auch sagen, ich persönlich würde lieber, wenn ich wirklich den kommerziellen Nutzen vermeiden würde, Share-Alike angeben als Non-Commercial, weil man sich wirklich in so einer ganz blöden Grauzone mit Non-Commercials...
Share-Alike im Sinne von, ich verpasste ihm jetzt mal hier diese Lizenz und ihr seid einfach nur das Beibehalten. Mein Wille bleibt sozusagen erhalten.
Das ist eigentlich unter Umständen eine schöne Sache, geht aber bei Knol jetzt nicht. Die Auswahl habe ich leider nicht, was schade ist, aber vielleicht kommt ja Google nochmal auf den Trichter, denn dieses Non-Commercial hilft nichts.
Können wir noch mal wieder zurück auf die Wikipedia. Wo siehst du denn jetzt so die primären Herausforderungen, um die Qualität in der Wikipedia zu verbessern? Ich meine, wir hatten jetzt das mit diesen gesichteten Versionen. Das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal eine technische Maßnahme, um das, was alle wollen, in irgendeiner Form durchzusetzen. Ob es den gewünschten Erfolg haben wird, muss man noch sehen. Ich finde jetzt so die ersten Ergebnisse sind eigentlich recht ermutigend.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Aber wie läuft denn diese Diskussion innerhalb der Wikipedianer ab? Und auch innerhalb dieser Administratoren-Riege, die ja so auch keiner richtig kennt und sieht?
Ja, kann man aber ein bisschen verfolgen auf den Diskussionsseiten.
Wenn man da die Zeit hat, ja.
Ja, das kostet natürlich viel Zeit. Aber wenn mir ein Thema am Herzen liegt, ich da selber drüber schreibe und dann merke, da laufe ich immer vor so einer Wand, da ist natürlich in der Tat dann auch ganz automatisch, dass ich auf die Diskussionsseiten schaue. Das glaube ich schon. Und dann kann ich mir schon einen guten Eindruck machen über den Zustand. Nee, es gibt ein paar Punkte, die gemacht werden müssen, also Herausforderungen, die vielleicht noch nicht von allen so entdeckt worden sind. Also was ich zum Beispiel beobachte, ist, dass die Artikel natürlich alle, insbesondere wenn etwas wirklich relevant ist, lang werden. Zum Teil sehr lang werden. Und es ist zwar schon, also alle Leute wissen das und haben das auch vor, dass man irgendwie am Anfang erstmal alles ein bisschen zusammenfasst, aber das ist noch nicht richtig gelungen. Und da muss man vielleicht noch irgendwie dran arbeiten, vielleicht, dass man oben auch direkt nochmal so ein besonderes, unterlegtes Feld hat oder so, dass wirklich Kurzinformationen an den Anfang kommen. Denn bei vielen Sachen, also bei diesen langen Artikeln, das geht einfach nicht. Also jetzt jemand, sagen wir mal, typische Anwendungsfall beim Journalismus. Da macht jemand eine Live-Sendung, so wie wir jetzt, und möchte mal kurz jetzt was wissen. Und das ist ein langer Artikel. Dann kann man natürlich nicht werden, man spricht so viel lesen. Aber es wäre schon mal ganz schön, wenn oben nicht nur, sagen wir mal, die Geburtsdaten von George Bush stehen, sondern schon mal alles Wichtige da steht. Also so in zehn Zeilen das Wichtigste, dass ich schnell überblicken kann. Also das wäre vielleicht nochmal an diese der Rat, dass so was mehr gefördert wird, bzw. dass die Wikipedia-Community das stärker merkt. Also da ist, glaube ich, noch eine große Herausforderung, wenn die Artikel werden immer länger. Man kann inzwischen schon sagen, dass es Artikel gibt, die fast schon ein Buch oder zumindest einen Heft-Charakter haben, wenn man das ausdrucken würde. Und da muss man wirklich daran arbeiten, dass oben die wichtige Information zusammengefasst ist. Und das ist noch nicht so. Also da besteht noch zu wenig Interesse. Also viele, auch exzellente Artikel enthalten nicht das Wichtigste oben. Also ein Artikel, an dem ich auch mitgearbeitet habe, die baskische Sprache, ist leider so, dass man wirklich, um einen Eindruck zu haben, diesen ellenlangen Artikel lesen muss. Da muss es irgendwie oben die Möglichkeit geben, dass man das Wichtigste noch mal zusammenfasst. Und das ist noch nicht...
Und siehst du da auch den Weg darin, so eine technische Unterstützung zu machen, dass man wirklich über die Software geht und...
Na ja, man muss irgendwie die Community dazu bringen, wie du sagst, kanalisieren, dass sie das auch wirklich macht. Und dazu muss man wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Feature dazu bauen, glaube ich.
In dem Zusammenhang fällt mir ein, es gibt ja eine zweite englische Wikipedia, die sogenannte simple.wikipedia.org. Die gibt es auch schon verdammt lange. So enthält mittlerweile allerdings auch sehr lange Artikel. Mein Verständnis war, korrigiere mich, dass das so eine Art Miniaturversion der Wikipedia ist, wo eine besonders einfache Sprache verwendet wird.
Ja, eigentlich ist es eine Sprachversion. Das ist Simple English.
Ja, aber wie ist denn Simple English definiert?
Ja, gute Frage. Also Simple English ist...
Ist das so, dass das auch Deutsche verstehen können? Oder ist das der Querschnitt aller... Dass wir in Australien, Afrikaner und Amerikaner zusammensetzen. Dass wir das, was wir am Lagerfeuer noch an Informationen austauschen können.
Ja, also Simple English ist natürlich ein Kompromiss. Es gibt tatsächlich, und das war zunächst eine Version von Wikipedia, nämlich Basic English. Basic English ist eine Plansprache. So ähnlich wie Esperanto, aber auf englischer Basis. Man nimmt englische Wörter und hat bestimmte Regeln, mit denen man die ganze Sache vereinfacht. Man verzichtet zum Beispiel auf komplexen Verben, aus dem Lateinischen entlehnte Verben, und nimmt die einfachen Verben, muss die dann noch mit solchen Präpositionen, Präpositionen möchte ich nicht sagen, weil das eigentlich mehr Adverdien sind. So was wie put on und put up und so. Was natürlich auch nicht unbedingt einfach ist.
Nee, gerade das macht es bei uns richtig schwierig.
Das stimmt. Kennt man sich da nicht so aus.
Also es geht um geringeren Fortschritts sozusagen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen basic English, geringerer Fortschritts. Bestimmte grammatische Sachen sind auch nicht so erlaubt. Neben Gerundien und so, das soll man auch nicht machen. Aber vor allen Dingen Wortschritts. Aber basic English ist im Grunde zu komplex, weil das ist ja wirklich eine Plansprache. Wo einer genau gesagt hat, so soll es sein, so nicht sein und so. Und dann gibt es auch nochmal was anderes, was in die ähnliche Richtung geht, was nicht so genau geregelt ist. Ach so, bei basic English gibt es auch glaube ich sogar eine Wortschrittsbeschränkung. Ich glaube, basic English darf nur 850 Wörter haben oder so. Da gibt es irgendwie so eine Liste von Wörtern, die sehr gering ist. Damit kommt man natürlich nicht klar, wenn man wirklich komplexe Sachverhalte verwenden will. Und dann gibt es auch noch das sogenannte Voice of America Special English. Das ist geschaffen worden, um halt der Radiosender Voice of America eben für...
Damit es auch Soldaten verstehen können.
Nein, damit das nicht englische Wuntersparnachstück, aber für Soldaten vielleicht auch. Da hab ich gar nicht gedacht.
No Offense meant.
Es gibt verschiedene Initiativen. Also einmal so eine Art Plansprache, einmal wirklich ein erleichtertes Englisch, wo man versucht hat, also nicht ganz so rigide wie Basic Englisch, aber auch so was zu schaffen. Und das ist jetzt hier die Synthese. Das heißt, man kann also, man muss sich nicht so ganz strikt an die Regeln halten von Basic Englisch. Also zum Beispiel Basic Englisch, das bekannte Beispiel, das immer kommt, das Wort für Tears, also Tränen, ist kein Basic Englisch-Wort. Da sagt man irgendwie...
Drop from the high.
Und das ist wirklich zu schwer, das macht die Sachen sehr, insbesondere wenn man komplexe Sachen vermitteln will, geht das einfach nicht. Und deshalb hat man hier...
Eye water of a clown.
So ein Mittelweg gefunden, dass man sich bemüht, einfach komplexe Ausdrucksweisen zu vermeiden, aber eben jetzt nicht in das andere Extrem verfolgen.
Okay, jetzt mal meine Idee, die ich gerade hatte, was wäre, wenn man jetzt die deutsche Wikipedia nimmt und einfach alles hinter der Einleitung wegschmeißt und sozusagen nur für sich nochmal publiziert. Da müssen wir noch relativ schnell feststellen, ob die Einleitung ausreichend ist oder nicht.
Ja, das wäre interessant, den Test müssen wir mal machen. Also wahrscheinlich sind sie nicht ausreichend, gerade bei Personen.
Und wenn es nur so ein Read-only-Ding ist, dass man sagen kann, bei diesem Artikel weiß ich nicht, was Sache ist. Oder vielleicht auch, dass man es editieren kann, keine Ahnung. Das ist eine dumme Idee, die mir gerade zwischendurch gekommen ist. Ich überlege gerade, da wir den großen Themenbereich, den wir tangieren wollten, auch schon ganz gut erreicht haben, können wir vielleicht mal die Option öffnen, auch Fragen noch mit reinzunehmen. Sollte jetzt hier tatsächlich jemand live... Ich muss erst mal hier ins Studio richten. Mir wird jetzt hier gerade die Telefonnummer gezeigt. Also hier sind alle Leitungen geschaltet. Also die eine. Also solltet ihr Fragen haben, und zwar jetzt gar nicht mal unbedingt nur jetzt zu dem, worüber wir gesprochen haben, sondern zur Wikipedia im Allgemeinen, oder? Dann könnt ihr das tun. Und zwar, die Telefonnummer lautet 030. Also in Berlin sind wir natürlich, klar. 66 40 49 50. Und wenn man anruft, dann macht es hier Klingelingeling. Und dann können wir mich hier auch einfach mal direkt mit reinnehmen. Mal schauen, vielleicht klappt das ja, vielleicht auch nicht. Aber ich wollte noch mal so, bis wir hier was haben, noch mal so diese Qualitätsfrage. Ich hatte ja gefragt, was wird so diskutiert? Also was sind sozusagen die Herausforderungen für die Qualität in der Wikipedia? Jetzt haben wir so ein paar Sachen schon abgehandelt. Fällt dir da jetzt noch ein weiterer Aspekt ein?
Ja, also es fällt da noch viel ein. Also ich bin auch extrem überrascht gewesen. Also sagst du, jetzt haben wir schon das Wichtigste. Jetzt können wir mal die Anrufer...
Ich rechne jetzt nicht wirklich mit Anrufern.
Nein, ich sag nur, dass schon so viel Zeit vergangen ist.
Ja, ja, wir sind schon im Endspurt. Hier ist Live-Sendung. Hier ist nach zwei Stundenfeld die Guillotine.
Ja, also was ich sagen wollte, ich hatte vorhin das angesprochen mit der Zusammenfassung am Anfang. Das ist so ein Punkt. Der andere Punkt ist eben auch, dass gewisse Dinge auf Einzelartikel verteilt sind, die eigentlich so ein bisschen zusammengehören, wo man vielleicht auch nochmal bestimmte Einzelaspekte zu größeren zusammenfassen könnte. Und das ist auch ein gewisses Desirat, also die gesamte Artikelstruktur, was ist als Einzelartikel zu behandeln, was gehört vielleicht in größeren Artikel, vielleicht auch tatsächlich da, dass man vielleicht mehr Wiederholungen zulässt. Denn wenn ich einen komplexen Artikel lese, zum Beispiel über den Bundestag oder so, dann will ich natürlich alle Einzelaspekte da auch noch mal irgendwie drin haben, will aber bei bestimmte Dinge noch mal Einzelartikel haben.
Bei Ländern hat man das ganz häufig. Die Wirtschaft Kenias oder so, was dann nicht unter Kenia steht, weil das einfach noch mal separat ist.
Und das ist im Moment noch nicht so gut gelöst. Das ist mal so, mal so. Also ich hatte mich neulich mal über Liberia informieren wollen, dann gibt es natürlich Geschichte Liberias, es ist ein extra, das war jetzt in der englischen Wikipedia, gibt es einen extra Artikel. Und da gibt es aber schon einen Teil im Hauptartikel und so. Und das ist auch nicht so ganz deckungsgleich gewesen. Gut, ich hab natürlich beides dann gelesen. Aber das ist noch mal ein großes Problem. Und da ist auch bisher so ein bisschen, hab ich das Gefühl, in der Community wird eher die Meinung vertreten, dass nichts doppelt sein soll. Da gibt es auch diesen Baustein, den man da einbauen kann, wenn man meint, zwei Artikel sind zu sehr deckungsgleich.
Das findet man häufig. Überschneidet sich thematisch mit dem anderen.
Aber eigentlich ist das nicht so schlimm. Eigentlich ist das sogar förderungswürdig. Weil ich wirklich, wenn ich einen Artikel über, sagen wir mal, Liberia lese, natürlich will ich da auch was über die Geschichte wissen, aber ich will nicht jedes Detail über die Geschichte wissen. Also das ist schon so, dass ich das einfach auch doppeln muss. Und wenn ich jetzt über ein bestimmtes Ereignis in einem Staat nochmal was lesen will, über eine Revolution oder Putsch oder so, dann soll es da vielleicht auch nochmal ein extra Artikel dazu geben. Weil wenn mich das interessiert, ich auch einen ganz anderen Blick auf das ganze Umfeld habe. Also das sollte mehr auch ins Bewusstsein rücken, wobei es natürlich immer ein Problem gibt, nämlich dass die Information natürlich trotzdem irgendwie zusammenpassen muss. Und das ist auch meiner Meinung nach noch eine Herausforderung, die man in Angriff nehmen muss.
Ich trinke doch hier tatsächlich das Telefon und werde mal gucken, ob da auch eine Frage für uns dabei ist. Haben wir den jetzt schon irgendwie am Apparat?
Ja, hallo?
Ja, hallo, guten Tag.
Ich wollte euch erst mal zu eurer großartigen Sendung gratulieren.
Danke schön.
Ich habe selten so viel kompakte Information über Wikipedia gehört.
Über UKW oder über Internet?
Ich bin hier in der Grenze zu Panko angesiedelt.
Alles klar.
Also da kann man das noch kriegen, relativ gut.
Das tut ja in der Freiheit von der Grenze zu Panko.
Zum einen wollte ich nochmal sagen, der Kollege, ich weiß leider nicht, wie er heißt, der die ganze Zeit die Ausführungen macht, die Fragen beantwortet, der hat ja gemeint, die Zusammenfassungen bei Wikipedia werden doch relativ undeutlich bzw. würden sie nicht das erfüllen, was sie versprechen. Also der erste Absatz immer bei den Wikipedia-Artikeln.
Ja, also ich bin das, Maha oder Martin?
Hallo Martin, ich bin Robert. Ich persönlich empfinde das jetzt erstmal nicht so, aber ich bin natürlich auch Laie. Also ich denke schon, also die meisten Wikipedia-Artikel, die ich so anklicke, die vermitteln mir schon in den ersten 5-6 Zeilen das, was ich so im Grum denke, wissen zu wollen. So und wenn mich das dann vertiefend interessiert, dann gehe ich halt weiter und dann ist es auch wurscht, wie lang der Artikel ist. Also von daher weiß ich gar nicht, ist keine Kritik an deinem Kritikpunkt sozusagen, aber ich wollte ich nur mal so als Laie so mal sagen, als Verteidigung, vielleicht zur Wikipedia. Ich bin aber auch kein Wikipedianer. Ich habe aber eine ganz spezielle Frage. Und zwar ging es ja vorhin um diese Geschichte hier zitieren aus Wikipedia und dann ging es um dieses neue Google-Tool oder diese neue Veröffentlichung bei Google. Knol. Knol hast du ja genannt. Darf ich denn zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt einen Blog habe, darf ich denn zum Beispiel aus Wikipedia einen Absatz rauskopieren, in meinen Blog einfügen und dann unten drunter den Link zu Wikipedia setzen, der direkt zu diesem Artikel führt, oder muss ich jetzt noch alle Autoren extra angeben?
Ja, also zunächst mal würde ich sagen, besser ist, wenn du den Link auf eine Version machst. Musst du aber nicht. Also es hängt davon ab, was du darstellen willst. Aber wenn du tatsächlich ein Zitat aus Wikipedia nimmst, weil das Zitat vielleicht in der neuen Version ganz anders aussieht, und wenn es dir auf das Zitat wirklich ankommt, auf das wörtliche Zitat, dann solltest du unten drunter die Versionsnummer schreiben, damit man auch wirklich das Zitat wiederfindet.
Beziehungsweise den Link auf die entsprechende Version.
Das war eben die Frage, reicht denn einfach nur, dass ich praktisch drunter den Link setze? Den muss man ja dann nur noch anklicken, und dann kommt man ja auf den Originalartikel.
Ist das okay? Ja, also zitieren darfst du. Aber das hängt jetzt nicht mit der Lizenz der Wikipedia zusammen, sondern mit dem Zitatrecht. Du darfst also aus Texten zitieren. Das ist auch ganz kompliziert, das darf nicht zu viel sein und so. Aber das Zitatrecht ist ja ganz alt. Das wird nach Buchseiten und so.
Ja, weil du vorhin ja gemeint hast, im Zusammenhang mit deinem Buch, da müsstest du ja irgendwelche Listen von Autoren anlegen, von denen dieses Zitat stammt. Da wird ja praktisch aus Wikipedia noch mal verlinkt, verlinkt, verlinkt, verlinkt. Also so, ich müsste jetzt also nicht alle Links oder alle Autoren, die mal ursprünglich als Quelle irgendwo hergehalten haben, angeben, sondern ich müsste praktisch nur diesen Link zu diesem ursprünglichen Artikel setzen. Da bin ich rechtlich auf der sicheren Seite.
Beim Zitieren von Text bist du rechtlich auf der sicheren Seite. Ich habe das glaube ich ein bisschen missverständlich ausgedrückt.
Ja, du hast eben gesagt, man müsste es eben sehr genau machen. So kenne ich es auch aus wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten heraus. Man muss halt die Autoren angeben. Allerdings sind es eben bei Wikipedia sehr viele und man kann natürlich nicht alle jetzt in einem Blog beispielsweise.
Dir ging es glaube ich um die Grafiken.
Mir ging es um die Grafiken. Das Problem war für mich jetzt nicht der Text. Also zitieren darf man, also gerade kurze Zitate sind völlig unproblematisch und ich kann auch, wie gesagt, dann auf die Wikipedia verweisen und sagen, da steht das und da ist das Zitat her. Das ist auch hinreichend. Mir ging es um Abbildungen, vor allen Dingen aus Commons. Und da ist eben leider das Problem, dass viele Abbildungen nicht benutzbar sind, weil sie dann eben unter GFDL stehen.
Aber ist es denn nicht so, dass die Abbildungen, die in Wikipedia sind, sowieso irgendwie frei sind? Oder bezahlt Wikipedia für die Bilder, die sie dort veröffentlichen, Geld?
Nein, nein, also das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Die Bilder stehen, wenn nichts weiter dabei ist, eigentlich innerhalb der Wikipedia oder der GFDL. Bei Commons hat man dazwischen gemerkt, dass das nicht gut passt. Und viele Leute, die Bilder in Commons hochladen, stellen die unter tatsächlich Creative Commons Lizenzen. Weil Creative Commons für Bilder, für Abbildungen einfach besser passt als GFDL. Und das ist schon mal ein Vorteil. Aber es ist natürlich immer noch ein Problem, wenn jemand sagt, hier, ich stelle das unter die CC by Non-Commercial oder CC by Share-A-Like. Ich zwar mag als Lizenz, aber wenn man das da runterstellt, kann man das nicht so ohne Weiteres benutzen.
Den Urheber sozusagen. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel, lass uns doch mal auf eine einfache Ebene runterkommen und von diesen Fremd- oder Fachbegriffen weggehen. Hm, Entschuldigung, ist mal eine Bronchitis. Ich hatte zum Beispiel das, sagen wir mal ganz einfach, die NASA veröffentlichen ein Bild auf Wikipedia, oder Wikipedia veröffentlichen ein Bild von der NASA. Ja, und die NASA ist ja in dem Sinne, stellt sie doch ihre Bilder frei zur Verfügung, weil sie ja vom Steuerzahler sowieso bezahlt sind. Muss ich jetzt die Quelle angeben, Wikipedia, oder muss ich die Quelle angeben, NASA? Oder darf ich das überhaupt nehmen aus der Wikipedia-Datei?
Also es ist eine Regierungsinstitution. Und die US-amerikanischen Regierungsinstitutionen müssen alles, was sie veröffentlichen, als öffentlich veröffentlichen. Und damit kannst du das auch immer benutzen. Da brauchst du nicht mal anzugeben, wo du es her hast, sondern du kannst das einfach benutzen. Deshalb stellt sich die Frage gar nicht bei NASA-Abbildungen. Das ist auch der Grund, warum wir überall, wenn wir was vom Weltraum sehen, NASA-Abbildungen haben und nicht zum Beispiel europäische Sachen.
Woran sehe ich denn jetzt, wenn ich zum Beispiel so einen Wikipedia-Artikel anklicke und denke mir, okay, da ist ein schönes Foto zu dem Thema, das ich gerade immer im Blog verwende, ob ich dieses Bild verwenden kann oder nicht. Woran sehe ich es jetzt ganz konkret?
Klick auf das Bild, dann kommst du auf eine Seite, auf der stehen sollte, unter welcher Lizenz das Bild steht. Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Da steht dann auch, in einem Public Domain oder CC, also nicht All-Rice-Reserve, das geht nicht, oder GFDL oder was auch immer.
Was heißt denn GFDL?
GFDL ist die New Free Documentation License.
Unter der eigentlich 99% des Contents sozusagen. Der Text ist alles so. Bei den Bildern weiß ich nicht, Creative Commons ist vorne, aber auch nicht alles unbedingt ist Creative Commons, weil das eben dann die Leute entscheiden, die das hochladen. Manche wählen halt die andere Lizenz, da kann man halt nichts gegen machen.
Gut, trotzdem noch mal ganz konkret, woran merke ich es, dass ich es nehmen kann oder woran merke ich es? Das ist vielleicht umgekehrt. Woran merke ich, dass ich es auf gar keinen Fall nehmen darf?
Du kannst es eigentlich immer nehmen, weil natürlich der Content der Wikipedia schon frei ist, in Anführungsstrichen. Bloß es gibt eben verschiedene Lizenzen, unter denen diese Freiheit sichergestellt wird. Es gibt ja auch in einem Softwarebereich und eben jetzt auch hier sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen davon, was frei ist. Für manche Leute ist frei dann, wenn du machen kannst, was du willst. Für andere Leute ist frei dann frei, wenn es eben auch nur unter Bedingungen weitergegeben werden kann, dass es auch frei bleibt. Und dementsprechend sind diese Lizenzen, und das sind vor allem eben diese GNU-Lizenzen, das ist im Softwarebereich die GPL und jetzt eben übertragen auf Texte, Inhalte, ist es eben die GFDL. Die kommt halt eher so mit diesem Ansatz daher, und du musst jetzt bestimmte Auflagen erfüllen, damit eben auf keinen Fall diese Freiheit eingeschränkt wird. Die GFDL ist ein Produkt, auch aus der Computerszene, muss man dazu sagen. Das ist halt ursprünglich bei einem Linux-Projekt für die Dokumentation der Software verwendet und dafür auch geboren worden und stand von daher extrem unter dem Einfluss, wie eben diese GPL-Software-Lizenz funktioniert. Und das hat sich aber einfach an vielen Stellen als sehr hinterlich erwiesen. Das Ding ist nur, jetzt hat man damit mal angefangen, jetzt wird man es halt auch so schnell nicht los. Ich glaube, dass viele Leute jetzt in der Wikipedia-Bewegung, wenn sie jetzt heute nochmal neu entscheiden könnten, welche Lizenzen nehmen, nicht mehr auf die GFDL gehen würden, weil es einfach ärgerlich ist.
Also um deine Frage nochmal genau zu beantworten, anhand eines Beispiels.
Ja und was du vorhin auch für plädiert hast, nämlich praktisch beim langen Wikipedia-Artikel eine kurze Zusammenfassung dessen, was ich gefragt habe und nicht so eine Ausführung, von der ich praktisch kein Wort verstehe.
Genau, wir machen uns dann ein Beispiel. Du willst ein Bild von der Erde aus dem Weltraum haben. Gehst auf den Wikipedia-Artikel Erde.
Genau.
Da siehst du gleich schon mal ein schönes Bild. Und das sagst du dir, auch das will ich haben. Dann klickst du auf das Bild und dann kommst du auf eine Seite, die heißt Bild, the Earth seen from Apollo 17.jpg. So und wenn ich jetzt runterscrollen, dann sehe ich irgendwo eine Angabe ganz unten. Permission. Da sieht man, da ist so ein durchgestrichenes C.
No Copyright.
Da heißt es, da steht dann auch gleich nochmal dahinter, was es heißt, also durchgestrichenes C heißt, es gibt kein Copyright, aber es steht dann auch nochmal, this file is in the public domain, because it was created by NASA und so weiter. Und daran sehe ich, aha, wenn das ein durchgestrichenes C ist, kann ich mich gleich freuen und kann es benutzen. Ich kann jetzt noch mehr dazu erfahren, da sind noch sogenannte Warnings dabei. Die sind aber hier jetzt alle nicht so relevant. Also an dem durchgestrichenen C sehe ich, ich kann das benutzen.
Also das ist praktisch das Merkmal, an dem ich mich als totaler Computerleihe und Blocker, der sich ja verunsichert fühlt sozusagen durch sämtliche Urheberrechtsgeschichten und Abmahnungsgeschichten. Daran kann ich mich orientieren, wenn dieses C durchgestrichen ist, bin ich auf der sicheren Seite. Das ist meine Frage gewesen. Ich bedanke mich und ich bedanke mich auch für eure tolle Sendung.
Ich kann gleich mal das Gegenbeispiel hinterher werfen. Ich habe jetzt mal Handbremse eingegeben, um gleich ein ganz anderes Ding zu haben. Da ist auch ein schönes Bild von so einer Handbremse, wie sie im Auto ist. Wenn man da sich dann zur Comments durchklickt, dann steht eben dort, dieses Bild ist Gnu Free Documentation License. Da ist es dann eben nicht ganz so einfach, weil diese Lizenz mehr von einem abverlangt. Natürlich ignorieren viele Leute auch diese Lizenz. Das ist natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen das Gesetz der Straße. Aber am Ende will man es natürlich gerade, wenn man jetzt so eine akademische Publikation macht, ganz genau machen. So, jetzt müssen wir aber auch zum Ende kommen, denn, tausendmal erwähnt, ist eine Live-Sendung und jetzt haben wir noch zwei Minuten. Das heißt, deine Chance für eine dritte Ausgabe, Wikipedia bei Chaosradio Express. Aber hast du noch ein Schlusswort für uns?
Ja, also ich hoffe, dass das alle lesen, dass ich jetzt auch nochmal dazu animiert fühle, bei der Wikipedia gleich noch was zu machen, zu ändern und zu sichten und so.
Du bist ja jetzt eben so ein bisschen als Kritiker dargestellt worden, das kann ja eigentlich so nicht stehen bleiben. Du bist ja selber seit langer, langer Zeit Wikipedia-Aktivist und tatkräftig TT.
Ja, ich bin auch auf jeden Fall ein großer Verwächter der Wikipedia. Das bleibe ich einfach, weil ich am Anfang in der ersten Zeit immer ausgelacht wurde und sage, das klappt ja nicht, das klappt ja nicht. Und deshalb, wenn man da lange genug den Leidensdruck hat, dann ist es, wenn man jetzt immer allen zeigt, es klappt ja doch. Deshalb bin ich vielleicht auch nicht so der gute Kritiker. Aber ich finde, es ist ein tolles Projekt und eigentlich müssten da alle mitarbeiten. Wer es nicht tut, ist irgendwie selber schuld.
Genau. So, als allerletzten Nachtrag, wir haben hier mal eine schön interaktive Sendung. Das ist der Vorteil von live im Chat, da habe ich da noch einen Hinweis bekommen, was ich nämlich da im Hinterkopf hatte mit Google Knol. Man kann sich als Autor an den Einnahmen der gescheiterten Werbung beteiligen lassen. Das war das, was ich grob in Erinnerung hatte. Das ist natürlich interessant. Populärer Artikel wird geschrieben, man sagt, hier darf auch Werbung eingeblendet werden, generiert Geld und dann hat man ja im Prinzip eine Einnahme aus der eigenen Tätigkeit, was so doof nicht ist. Aber das war es jetzt. Das war Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 93. Die zweite, die live bei Funkwelle FM gesendet wird, aber nicht die letzte. Nächsten Sonntag und übernächsten Sonntag geht es da noch weiter. Nächsten Sonntag werden wir uns über Conversational Design unterhalten, eine sehr interessante Sendung, wo wir mal ein bisschen die bisherigen Ergebnisse der Web 2.0-Welle und überhaupt verschiedene Aktivitätsmeme im Internet analysieren wollen. Dieses Thema der Sendung danach steht noch nicht ganz fest, aber ich darf jetzt erstmal danke mal für dein Kommen. Danke Tim. Und danke für den Anrufer und die Zuhörer und die Leute, die im Chat mitgemacht haben und die uns auch mal wieder helfen beim Streamen. Ich sag jetzt Tschüss, bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.